Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, hast du mich grad Hurensohn genannt?
Nein, es waren Digitalisierungsfehler.
Netzpolitik Nummer 42 vom 7. Februar 202undzwanzig.
Ich brauche's jetzt glaube ich nicht zu erwähnen. Ihr wisst, alle was geschrieben steht und was uns allen bevorsteht. Bis dahin.
Machen wir weiter mit unserer dystopischen Berichterstattung, bevor alles besser wird. Wobei letztes Mal hatten wir ja wirklich schon einen extrem
Mangel an äh schlechten Nachrichten, die Nuss, oder? Also das war schon im kritischen Bereich, würde ich sagen.
Aber du weißt, das Schlimmste, was in diesem Land passiert, ist, dass ich unbescholtene Bundeswehroffiziere wie Marcel Bohnert von Super Holocaust-Überlebenden und deren PR Abteilung in der ARD in die braune Ecke treiben lassen.
Das ist das schlimme Tim, was hier passiert.
Aha.
So und dass die dass die Innenministerin sich äh irgendwie antifaschistisch engagiert. Wo kommen wir denn hin.
Ja, das geht ja nun auch überhaupt nicht, oder? Das ist ja also äh das habe ich jetzt auch gelernt. Also gegen Nazis sein ist jetzt schon linksextrem. Mhm.
Ja natürlich.
Aber aber äh keine Sorge, es war ein Digitalisierungsfehler, der der Welt da unterlaufen ist. Ja, es war natürlich eine Mitarbeiterin.
Zuvor zu einem anderen Thema gearbeitet hat, fragt man sich auch, welches andere Thema war das denn? Wo wo man auf die Idee kommt.
Ähm angeblich,
super linke durch Super Holocaust-Überlebende mit ihren PR-Abteilungen zu ersetzen und das wird jetzt als ein Digitalisierungsfehler
ja und das also was sagt es über dieses Land, dass du so dass du mit so einer Ausrede.
Offenbar durchkommst, weil alle sagen, Digitalisierungsfehler kennen weiß nix Neues passiert. Passiert in diesem Land öfter als man möchte.
Das deutsche Autokorrektur ist das.
Da passiert das einfach mal. Ja.
Ja.
Da geht immer was schief bei der Autokorrektur. In Deutschland ähm halt dann mal so was. Da muss man einfach mit rechnen. Ich meine man muss das Gute darin sehen, ja, wenn Digitalisierungsfehler.
Ihnen unterlaufen, dann bedeutet das, dass sie sich mit Digitalisierung beschäftigen und ich finde, das ist schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne. Es passiert.
Das kann keine keine 20 Jahre mehr dauern und ähm man wird von Fortschritten berichten können.
Ja, wobei ich mit diesem Verlag generell wenig Fortschritt äh zutraue und äh auch nicht wünsche, ja. Oh, was sind das für unangenehme also Ulf Pauschal ist wirklich unangenehme und unangenehme Zeitgenosse.
Unangenehmer Zeitgenosse. Und und so unaufrichtig auch, ne? Also man kann ja einfach auch mal sagen, habe ich so gesagt.
Könnte man ja sagen. Aber nein, du musst irgendeine Mitarbeiterin schuld sein, ja.
Ja, die muss dann vom Bus geschmissen werden.
Hach, sind die alle schwach? Na ja.
Aber äh wir äh wir haben was anderes gemacht. Wir haben uns nette Leute eingeladen und äh begrüßen hier unseren äh Gas für diese Sendung, nämlich den Jan Jan Penfrath. Hallo. Herzlich willkommen bei Laufbuch Buchnetzpolitik Jan.
Hallo, vielen Dank.
Jan, genau. Ähm unsere äh Hörerin äh kennen dich noch nicht, weil bist du das erste Mal hier und ähm.
Wir wollen auch gleich mal sagen, warum wir dich
äh eingeladen haben. Der Hauptgrund ist unser Romgeschwurbel rund um das Thema Digital Services Act Digital Markets Act. Da wollen wir nämlich heute mal ein bisschen,
nochmal eintauchen mit dir und du bist dafür äh prädestiniert, weil du bist auch einer von denen, die bei Ädry arbeiten in
äh Brüssel. Wir hatten ja hier schon,
verschiedenste äh Vertreter äh von Edri immer wieder mal da den äh Joe, den Kirsten und Thomas natürlich äh äh oft, solange er vor allem für Edri gewirkt hat. Ähm
Ja ähm vielleicht steigen wir erstmal mit dir ein bisschen ein. Vielleicht kannst du ja mal äh was äh sagen, wie wie es bei dir mit den Digitalisierungsfehlern so funktioniert hat bisher.
Du begleitest.
Einen hört man ganz leise im Hintergrund. Nein, das war ein Scher.
Das ist ja das ist der typische pandemische Digitalisierungsfehler.
Stimmt, kommt vom Alter her auch hin, ne? Dürfen wir das sagen?
Nehmen wir den nehmen wir in der Post alles raus.
Ähm genau, aber äh sagt doch mal, du äh wie bist du denn so in den Digital- äh Topf gefallen? Was was verbindet dich mit Netzpolitik, mit Technologie?
Mich bis heute auch, wie ich da eigentlich reingefallen bin. Ähm ich leite bei äh die im im Politikteam
äh Arbeit zum Digital Service Act und Digital Market sagt, also alles was irgendwie mit der Regulierung von Online-Plattformen zu tun hat
Ich bin eigentlich ähm von Haus aus Politikwissenschaftler und äh habe zwischenzeitlich als äh Journalist gearbeitet, als freischaffender für Goulem DE, was vielleicht auch vielen ein Begriff ist. Äh habe vor allem zum
natürlich Regulierung äh geschrieben auf europäischer Ebene, vor allem äh aber auch zu äh Open Source Software ähm IT-Sicherheit und und einer Reihe anderer.
Themen, ähm aber weil ich sowieso schon in Brüssel war und auch eine äh Uhr
Vergangenheit als ähm Unternehmenslobbyist habe ähm in meinem Logbuch habe ich gedacht, na gut, dann dann kann ich die beiden Dinge ja verbinden. Meine Technikbegeisterung und die Arbeit in der Politik und bin deswegen bei bei Edri gelandet.
Was was hast du da für eine Lobby äh Vergangenheit? Was was deckt das ab, warum?
Ich habe mal für eine Beratungsfirma gearbeitet, für sechs Jahre und äh diese Beratungsfirmen sind äh ja die die arbeiten halt für wer sie bezahlt. Also da bin ich durch alle,
Industriesektoren weggegangen äh vom Chemiesektor über die erneuerbare Energiendustrie ähm habe so querbeet alles gemacht.
Mhm. Wie wie wie evil ist das so?
Ziemlich. Insofern bin ich ganz froh daraus zu sein.
Kannst du vielleicht da mal einen kleinen Einblick geben? Finde ich interessant. Also ähm wie landet man da und und und wie sieht da so der Arbeitsalltag aus? Also inwiefern kann man sich denn da von den Themen auch entkoppeln?
Äh da kann man sich nur schwer von den Themen entkoppeln, denn am Schluss ähm hat so eine Beratungsfirma halt Unternehmen als Kunden. Die möchten gerne ihre Interessen durchgesetzt sehen auf europäischer Ebene.
Und äh und da widmet knallharten Bandagen gekämpft, also
Sagen sich halt, ja wir wollen äh, dass das Gesetz so und so am Schluss aussieht. Wir bezahlen eine teure Beratungsfirma, dass die das für uns möglich macht. Ähm und dann laufen die Leute in der Beratungsfirma los und äh äh überzeugen halt, wo sie können.
Entscheidungsträgerinnen und Entscheidungsträger.
Also du bist also im klassischen Klinkenputzen sozusagen unterwegs gewesen, hast Termine gemacht und dann den äh eingeredet so ja hier
Aber ich meine, die wissen doch auch, wer da kommt und die wissen doch auch, wie's läuft. Also ich meine, wir wissen auch, dass du quasi da so ein
ich sag mal überspitzt und Politik sollten da äh bis dem
dem jetzt da so die die Bullet Points eingetrichtert wurden, wie wie gehen die denn mit dir um? Also.
Das ist ja unterschiedlich ähm aber merkt schon, dass äh und ich
habt auch gar kein Problem das so offen zu sagen, dass äh grade im im äh konservativen Liberalen Teil Spektrum äh im im Parlament äh dass da tatsächlich auch offene Türen da sind, wenn man halt sagt hier ich vertrete dieses oder jenes Unternehmen ähm das sind so und so viele Arbeitsplätze in deinem Wahlkreis
und hier ist was wir wollen. So und,
ist notwendig, damit das Unternehmen erfolgreich ist. Ähm manchmal stimmt das auch. Manchmal ist das ein bisschen an den Wahan herbeigezogen. Das hängt dann irgendwie davon ab, wie gut die Argumente des Unternehmens jeweils halt sind.
Aber am am Schluss sind das äh sind das Argumente, die die erschreckend häufig ziehen.
Mhm. Und dann, wie geht man dann so vor.
Das in meiner Arbeit jetzt bei Edri natürlich ganz anders.
Klar, da können wir auch gleich drauf kommen, aber ich wollte mal diesen Kontrast nochmal kurz äh aufspinnen, weil ich meine ist ja, du hast ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch einen Vorteil, weil du halt diese Seite auch aktiv
ausgelebt hast so und sicherlich auch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise auch zu kritisieren gefunden hast.
Ja, also ich ist es in der in jeder in jedem Fall äh ist es ähm interessant und spannend zu sehen, wie erfolgreich Unternehmenslobbyisten sind. Ähm nicht nur in der in der Tech-Industrie, sondern in vielen Industriebereichen. Ähm
das hängt zum Teil mit damit zusammen, dass die einfach mehr Ressourcen zur Verfügung haben. Ähm die können mehr Leute dran setzen an ein bestimmtes Thema
aber auch wie gesagt weil eben bestimmte Argumente wie das Arbeitsplatzargument oder ja allgemein eben solche Wirtschafts
lastigen Argumente ähm dann doch
für einige Politikerinnen und Politiker doch wichtig sind. Einfach wichtiger manchmal als wenn dann ein Zivilgesellschaftsvertreter um die Ecke kommt und sagt hier ähm Menschenrechte.
Also um das äh vielleicht zu mal Avocados, Diaboli auch zu erklären, warum das eine Rolle spielt. Ähm.
Also es ist ja schon nicht verkehrt, dass die Parteien oder die politischen Vertreter sich darüber Sorgen machen, was weiß ich, wie's um den.
Wirtschaftlichen um die wirtschaftliche Zukunft des Landes aussieht oder so, ne. Aber in dieser.
Welt, in der wir jetzt leben, gerade in der Internetgeschichte
Es ist natürlich eigentlich auch so ein so ein Race to the Bottom, ne? Ich fühle mich gerade motiviert
ein ein Thema kurz anzusprechen, was wir eigentlich gerne später gehabt hätten, aber weil's gerade so schön passt
ähm würde ich's einfach mal kurz nach vorne nehmen, weil da gibt's auch gar nicht so viel zu sagen, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass du da was zu zu sagen hast, Jan. Ähm
Facebook hat jetzt in der Meldung an die also in die Securitys in in Exchange-Commission quasi so ein.
Wirtschaftsberichte, wie läuft es gerade bei uns? Abgeliefert und da müssen sie ja quasi ihre Risiken schildern. Und da haben sie gesagt, ja eines der Risiken, die bei uns aufm Horizont sind, ist.
Wie wird,
quasi Shrimps zwei jetzt geklärt, also es gab ja erst den Privacy Schiel, nee was gab's als erstes? Du wirst mir helfen.
Safe habe.
Erst gab's Safe Harvard, dann gab's das Gleiche ihn als äh Privacy Shield,
jetzt äh wurde ja quasi gesagt, okay, die Standardsvertragsklauseln passen nicht, also Facebook braucht irgendeine Rechtsbasis für den Datentransfer und jetzt haben sie quasi in ihren Bericht an die SEC geschrieben. Ja, hömma, wenn das so weitergeht, dann,
gibt es für uns das ähm wirtschaftliche Risiko, dass wir den Betrieb in Europa einstellen müssen,
Ja, was natürlich also was, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, da werden die sich auch Gedanken drüber gemacht haben, natürlich ein Risiko ist und es wäre natürlich toll, wenn sich dieses Risiko manifestieren würde, aber was natürlich gleichzeitig eine.
Also quasi eine Drohung oder ein ein auf seine eigenen
Interessen in dieser Auseinandersetzung aufmerksam machen ist, was einerseits in Richtung der USA signalisiert, strengt euch da bitte an und gleichzeitig in Richtung der EU signalisiert. Freunde, wenn ihr uns hier ähm,
blöd kommt, dann wollen wir mal gucken, äh wie lange ihr ohne Facebook auskommt. Das wird wahrscheinlich keine fünf Minuten gehen und ähm,
das ist also ich glaube, dass halt dieses dieses wirtschaftliche Argument leider eben auch immer zur Folge hat, dass dann eben die Wirtschaft den den längeren Hebel hat, ne.
Finde ich ein sehr schönes Beispiel, ähm denn das das zeigt tatsächlich, dass äh dass solche Unternehmen eben Druck machen können, egal wie absurd das Argument ist, äh am Ende. Ähm da musst du am Schluss nur die Angst äh bei genügend Politikern und Politikern groß genug sein.
Eventuell wahr sein könnte und und dann kann das schon einen Einfluss haben.
Die Angst davor haben, dass Facebook sich vom Markt zieht.
Gibt's glaube ich einige, ja?
Ich glaube, also die haben halt dann Angst ähm also.
Ich glaube, dass dass die Angst haben, dann so dazustehen wie Axel Voss, ne, der das der zwischendurch mal eben das Internet äh versehentlich verbieten wollte, weil er nicht zugehört hat, wenn ihm jemand was gesagt hat. Aber ähm.
Also natürlich werden die es vermeiden, sich mit Facebook anzulegen, ne? Zu über die Maße.
Ich glaube auch, ja.
Da gibt es natürlich auch Interessen. Ne, man kann jetzt ordentlich sagen, so äh nur weil wir Facebook jetzt Scheiße finden, äh weg damit, äh keiner kräht danach, ne?
Ist das etwa kein legitimes Interesse.
Ja von unserer Position auch äh sicherlich nachvollziehbar mit Tannen Cheek aber du weißt auch wie viele
kleinst äh Unternehmer mittlerweile da auf Facebook auch tatsächlich so ihre einzige Heimat äh und all ihre Kundenbeziehungen haben, die sie sich über Jahre aufgebaut haben und äh denen erkläre dann mal.
Was wie die dann so dastehen. Ja also das das das macht sicherlich auch keinen Spaß und von daher ist die Debatte natürlich schwierig.
Ganz zu schweigen, dass es natürlich ein paar hundert Millionen äh Nutzerinnen und Nutzer gibt in Europa, die die Facebook nutzen und vielleicht auch nutzen wollen. Ähm und äh die würden ihren gewählten Abgeordneten übers Dach steigen, wenn wenn Facebook plötzlich weg wäre.
Da würde ich.
Würde ich auf äh auf jeden Fall von ausgehen. Gleichzeitig ist natürlich äh diese diese öffentliche Bekanntgabe von Facebook im Prinzip im Prinzip die Dokumentation ihres Desinteresses
äh sich den Gesetzen zu unterwerfen, ja. Also die einzig
sinnvolle Antwort in einem Europa wo den ganzen Tag von Souveränität und was ich einem gesprochen wird in einem Deutschland in dem die Innenministerin sich von Google die Telefonnummer von
Telegram geben lassen muss so ungefähr, äh wäre natürlich dann schon die richtige Antwort zu sagen, ja genau, wenn du dich hier an die Regel nicht hälst, dann äh pack ein, ne, packst deine Sachen, super, komm auch ohne dich klar, aber es ist schon interessant, wie sowohl.
Die Innenministerin, die eine derartige Andeutung in Richtung Telegram gemacht hat, ne, den den Geschäftsbetrieb hier einzustellen. Das gleichzeitig, ne, wenn Facebook damit droht, also.
Das allen irgendwie klar ist, dass das nicht eintreten wird, ne.
Das ist schon das illustriert natürlich schon. Die macht einerseits von Telegram und auch die Macht von äh von Google in dem Bereich und das ist eigentlich natürlich
erstmal nicht unbedingt als positiv zu betrachten, wenn ähm.
Unternehmen einen derartigen Druck ausüben können, um ihre Interessen durchzusetzen, ne.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch nichts Neues, dass jetzt große Unternehmen Druck ausüben können. Das hast du halt in der Industrie äh äh genauso. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, Jan, welche Art von Unternehmen du so vertreten hast? Ist das so alles Mögliche gewesen oder gab's da einen Schwerpunkt?
Äh war eine schöne Mischung. Ich hatte an äh Zahlungsanbietern Online-Zahlungsanbieter und Konkurrenten von PayPal äh ich hatte ein großes Chemieunternehmen, ich hatte einen Hersteller von Herdplatten äh also durch die Bank weg alles da.
Herdplatten, okay. Ja gut, also ne die die Stärke ein großer Unternehmen, die drückt sich immer aus, ne? Ist die Frage, ob jetzt die Internetplattform hier noch mal eine andere Qualität mit reinbringen?
Ich glaube die ähm die Macht, die die großen ähm äh Tech-Unternehmen äh gesammelt, angesammelt haben, einfach in
die schiere Menge an Ressourcen, die sie haben, äh die Menge an Nutzerinnen und Nutzern, die sie haben, was natürlich dann gewisser,
Abhängigkeiten schafft äh für ganze Blender, für ganze Gesellschaften, für politische Systeme zum zum Teil
für Wirtschaftssysteme, das das ist schon etwas, was ich so in anderen Industrien noch nicht gesehen habe,
Gibt's immer Interdependenzen zwischen den verschiedenen Abhängigkeiten, zwischen den verschiedenen Sektoren äh in der Industrie, da gibt's natürlich auch Sachen, wo man dann immer drauf gucken muss, aber aber in der Größenordnung
und ja das das ist glaube ich schon etwas etwas Neues und das zeigt sich auch in der Art und Weise wie die Lobby-Schlacht jetzt um den,
um den Digital Services Aggro in Digital Markets sagt, ich will das nicht vorwegnehmen, aber äh jetzt stattgefunden hat bisher ähm das ist schon, das hat eine Dimension angenommen, wie wie wir es zumindest äh jetzt schon seit seit langem nicht mehr gesehen haben.
Genau, dann lass uns doch mal genau auf das Thema jetzt auch äh kommen. Also.
Vor allem der Digital Services Act, den wir denen auch erstmal so äh ins Auge wir haben das halt hier schon,
gesprochen mit Patrick Breyer. Wir haben's äh links und rechts immer mal wieder ein bisschen äh erwähnt, aber wir würden uns gerne nochmal da so ein bisschen auf deine Perspektive jetzt freuen.
Was ist es? Also wir reden jetzt von einem Vorschlag, das ist ja sozusagen noch nicht beschlossene Sache, ein Vorschlag der aktuellen
Kommission der,
EU, also die Laienkommission von der Leyen-Kommission und hier geht's halt um ein Paket von.
Haftungssicherheitsvorschriften äh für digitale äh Plattformen und das Ganze ist so ein bisschen die Vision, den dieses Großprojekt des Digitalen.
Binnenmarkts abzuschließen, sage ich mal, ne. So kann man das glaube ich formulieren, ne.
Das Gesetz heißt ja auf Deutsch digitale Dienste gesetzt. Es geht also wirklich um die Regulierung, das Kreieren, das Schaffen neuer Regeln, eines Regelungsrahmens für digitale Dienste, ähm die Notwendigkeit für das Gesetz kommt auch ein bisschen daher aus Sicht der EU.
Die aktuelle Rechtslage schon sehr alt ist. Die hat sich seit 20 Jahren nicht verändert und ähm und hier ist also die Idee gewesen, hey vor 20 Jahren die ganzen großen Plattformen, Facebook, Google
gab's alle noch nicht und deswegen ist die Rechtslage derzeit auch nicht angemessen. So ist da die Vorstellung und man müsste das jetzt also anpassen ähm um eben die äh Art und Weise wie die Plattformen
agieren auf dem europäischen Markt, aber auch im Umgang mit Nutzerinnen und Nutzern, äh dass das neu geregelt wird.
Und äh die der Ansatzpunkt, der erste Ansatzpunkt für die EU war zu sagen ähm wie welche Verantwortung hat denn eigentlich eine Online-Plattform wie Facebook oder wie Twitter oder wie YouTube,
für Inhalte, die von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern dort gepostet werden. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn die ähm.
Wenn da illegale Inhalte dabei sind. Ähm also Sachen, die einfach verboten sind, zu veröffentlichen.
Oder zu sagen ähm und was machen wir mit Inhalten, die vielleicht nicht illegal sind, aber trotzdem irgendwie.
Schädlich für manche Leute vielleicht, also auf auf Englisch nennen sie das immer so schön harmvoll äh Content, ähm aber ohne genau zu sagen, was das eigentlich
bedeutet und und mit einschließt. Ähm und so das war so der Anfangspunkt und darauf aufbauend kamen dann immer neue Regelungen und Ideen oben drauf und jetzt im politischen Prozess äh dann von den Institutionen dann eben auch noch mal neue Ideen. Insofern ist es jetzt ein ziemlich großes und komplexes Gesetz geworden.
Mhm. Gab ja mit dem Netzwerkdurchsetzungs äh Gesetz in Deutschland im Prinzip ja auch schon so einen ersten.
Vorstoß in diese Richtung, ne und äh ist da eigentlich auch genau in diese in diese äh Definitionsfalle ein wenig äh reingelaufen. Das war, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen Motivation das Ganze überhaupt erst äh in Angriff zu nehmen.
Ja. Äh Deutschland hat sehr sehr hart äh äh quasi äh Druck ausgeübt, äh hat versucht äh den
dass der Digital Services Act der DSA äh quasi nach nach dem nach dem Bilde des Netz DEG gestaltet wird. Die wollten natürlich gerne ihre eigene
so wie sie selbst sagen, Erfolgsgeschichte irgendwie europäisch exportieren
Das hat aber nur zum Teil geklappt und jetzt aus ähm Menschenrechts- oder digitalrechtlicher Perspektive bei ETRI, sagen wir halt zum Glück
das Netz-TG hat eine Reihe an Regeln drin, die sich ähm die sich die nicht kompatibel sind mit dem Schutz der freien Meinungsäußerung, die ähm.
Die Anreize setzen für Plattformen, äh Inhalte schneller zu löschen, als das eigentlich der Fall sein sollte.
Und äh und insofern sind wir ganz froh, dass das was jetzt
im Vorschlag des DSA drinsteht. Ähm da sensibler mit diesem Thema umgeht, grade mit dem Thema Meinungsfreiheit.
Das Netz-TG ähm äh
hat ja ganz klare Löschfristen etabliert. Also wenn äh jetzt Facebook äh darauf hingewiesen wird, dass da irgendjemand irgendwas gepostet hat, was angeblich Illegale ist, dann hat Facebook nur eine bestimmte Zeit, spannende Zeit äh diese Inhalte zu bearbeiten und möglicherweise dann auch zu löschen, eine Entscheidung zu fällen.
Und das führt zu zwei Dingen. Zum einen nämlich, dass Facebook da unter Zeitdruck eine sehr komplexe, häufig komplexe Entscheidung, eine Legalitätsentscheidung treffen muss und zum zweiten, dass Facebook überhaupt in die Situation
Gerät quasi wie ein Quasi-Gericht ähm über das rechtmäßige und unrechtmäßige in online äh Inhalten zu entscheiden. Ähm und das äh und das hat eben hochproblematische Auswirkungen auf.
Wie die wie Facebook das macht und ähm und da hat der DSA eben jetzt gesagt, die Kommission gesagt, das machen wir im DSA nicht, ähm sondern wir sagen den Plattformen nur
ihr müsst das bearbeiten, wie ihr diese Inhalte behandelt, muss transparent sein, es muss verständlich sein, Nutzerinnen, Nutzer müssen eingebunden sein, ähm aber es gibt keine feste äh fix fixe Löschfrist quasi, ähm weil eben dieser Anreiz des Schnelllöschens gar nicht erst entstehen soll auf europäischer Ebene.
Mhm. Und wie es jetzt so.
Eurer Perspektive, also damit meine ich natürlich jetzt die die Edri, wie wie wie positioniert sich jetzt in diesem ganzen Verhandlungsmarathon.
Wo steht ihr da? Was sind so die Sachen, auf die ihr jetzt primär euch fokussiert?
Äh es ist ein bisschen vielleicht ein bisschen überraschend für uns äh als zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation. Wir bezeichnen uns ja auch selbst so ein bisschen als Watchdog auf europäischer Ebene, aber ich muss sagen, dass wir
eigentlich recht positiv überrascht waren von dem Vorschlag ähm der Europäischen Kommission ähm als der vor einem Jahr ungefähr ähm
vorgeschlagen wurde. Ähm eben weil wir den Eindruck hatten, die Kommission hat hier sehr viel ähm Hirnschmalz reingesteckt, hat versucht die Fehler, die auf deutscher Ebene und auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern gemacht wurden, nicht zu wiederholen. Ähm gleichzeitig ähm war der Vorschlag der Kommission auch nicht besonders innovativ.
Also da gibt's eine ganze Reihe an Sachen, die wir gerne drin gehabt hätten, die da nicht drin waren. Deswegen umso besser, dass das Europäische Parlament als,
Co-Gesetzgeberin ähm hier diese Innovationen anschließend dann eingefügt hatten. Als Beispiel möchte ich nennen, vor allem das Verbot von oder
teilweise Verbot inzwischen von Tracking-Werbung ähm etwas, was wir eben den Plattformen sehr, sehr gerne auferlegen möchten, weil wir glauben, dass die dass das dass die ganze Wirtschaft, die ganze Datenwirtschaft, die hinten an die Tracking-Werbung drankommt, die
dies die ganze Cookie-Banner-Situation in der wir uns seit Jahren befinden, die wirklich nervig ist. Ähm dass all das eben perfekt im im DSA eigentlich reguliert werden kann und müsste ähm und äh
genau und also da gibt's ein paar Regelungen wie so was, die die die da drin stehen jetzt äh und das ist ist sehr gut. Problem natürlich, das Parlament hat die Sachen eingefügt, die Mitgliedsstaaten wiederum auf europäischer Ebene
haben diese ganzen Innovationen nicht mit drin in in ihrer eigenen Position und die müssen jetzt natürlich einen Kompromiss finden und es ist noch längst nicht ausgemacht,
werde am Schluss das Rennen macht.
Kannst du mal die Cookie-Banner-Situation, ja? Die finde ich ja auch immer sehr schön, wenn man mit äh so,
hm haben wir aber jetzt wohl nur peripher, digitalpolitisch interessierten Leuten redet, ähm.
Wenn du jetzt irgendjemand fragt, Andy, die EU-Wattenquatsch, ey, ich kann keine Internetseite mehr sehen wegen scheiß Staat. Äh erklär doch mal, wie es zu diesen Cookie-Bannern kommt.
Ja, die Cookie, die Cookie Banner kommen eigentlich daher, dass ja, dass in erste die EU hat ein Gesetz erlassen, welches es vorschreibt, dass
Bevor eine Webseite oder eine App oder,
wer auch immer. Persönliche Daten von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern verwenden kann, um gezielt Werbung auszuspielen, muss man vorher um Erlaubnis fragen
ja? Und diese Einwilligung, diese Erlaubnis versuchen diese Cookie-Banner einzuholen. Ähm
Unternehmen, die diese Werbung ausspielen wollen, haben aber sehr schnell festgestellt, dass wenn man dann einfach ein Fenster aufmacht und sagt, darf ich dich für Werbung ausspähen, ja oder nein?
Dann die meisten Leute halt nein klicken.
Ach.
Werbeindustrie gesagt.
Die finden alles raus, ne.
Ne also es ist so einfach ist das am Schluss und,
die Cookie-Bahn, die Werbeindustrie hat sich dann gesagt, na gut, dann müssen wir die Cookie-Banner halt so gestalten, dass am Schluss alle ja klicken und das haben die gemacht und deswegen sind Cookie-Banner heute scheiße und unbenutzbar.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an diesen äh dieses Thema, was wir bei damals auch behandelt hatten und auch jahrelang ähm dass YouTube gesagt hat, in deinem Land.
Wir dieses Video, was total geil ist, leider nicht zeigen wegen der GEMA
ja? Obwohl eigentlich der Hintergrund war, dass YouTube einfach quasi nicht bereit war der GEMA-Geld zu geben jetzt unabhängig davon, was man jetzt von der Geber hält. Aber wie wie quasi
ne, wie man wie man das schafft da so eine Massentäuschung herbeizuführen, dass sich dann alle gegen letztendlich eine eine
ja doch sehr sinnvolle Gesetzgebungen bewegen. Ich gebe zu, ich benutze auch natürlich einen Cookie-Banner-Blocker,
um äh ein Internet ohne diesen Unsinn äh benutzen zu können. Bei den meisten Seiten funktioniert der sogar halbwegs. Aber äh ist schon spannend, wie diese was wir gerade sagten, ne, wie diese Unternehmen es immer wieder schaffen,
die Gesetze, die gegen ihre Interessen gehen, so ein bisschen so umzudeuten
ja das das das Menschen sich hinstellen und sagen wie ich darf nicht mehr Diesel fahren nur wegen dem Eisbär oder so was ne das ist ja alles äh das gelingt denen schon immer ganz gut.
Und bei aller Liebe, man kann fast nur Bösartigkeit unterstellen, denn was wir jetzt in unserer Lobbyarbeit sehen, ist, dass halt die großen Tech-Unternehmen jetzt um die Ecke kommen und sagen, ja, guck
doch mal, wir müssen diese blöden Cookie-Banner loswerden. Unsere Nutzerinnenutzer leiden so unter der Situation. Das Gesetz muss die jetzt abschaffen. Ähm und äh und am besten uns die Datenverarbeitung
so einfach so erlauben. Ähm und äh das ist halt die die machen das System absichtlich kaputt, beschweren sich hinterher und sagen, siehst du, das Gesetz muss abschaffen, das das.
Bringt doch alles nix. Ähm also da ist glaube ich das ist einfach eine Strategie und die äh funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Insofern also doppelt cool, dass das Europäische Parlament in seiner Position zum
DSA gesagt hat, ähm nicht nur Tracking-Werbung mit besonders sensiblen, persönlichen Daten geht gar nicht, ähm auch nicht mit Einwilligung, ist einfach verboten, sondern sie haben auch gesagt, ähm diese diese
Cookie-Banner, die einen halt so reindrängeln irgendwo ja zu sagen, wo man eigentlich lieber nein sagen will. Auch die würden in Zukunft verboten.
Werden. Da gibt's tatsächlich auch eine im Gesetzesentwurf steht da eine Liste, eine bunte Bullet-Point-Liste drin, wie so eine Banner zum Beispiel aussehen, einfach Beispiele.
Und solche zum Beispiel wären dann wären dann in Zukunft verboten wenn es eben nach der Meinung des des Parlaments geht am Schluss.
Also eigentlich eine ziemlich coole coole Entwicklung. Wir müssen einfach nur schauen, dass das jetzt eben auch eine Mehrheit findet am Schluss.
Aber im Parlament gibt's dafür eine Mehrheit.
Im Parlament gibt's dafür eine Mehrheit, ja.
Okay, Trekking-Werbung. Also das äh notieren wir mal als äh könnte cool sein. Also.
Ja, um das mal so ein bisschen zu verorten, ne, weil es ist ja auch glaube ich immer so man hat ja, glaube ich.
Die Jahre immer so ein bisschen gelernt so, oh mein Gott,
EU will irgendwas am Internet anfassen, das kann ja alles nur schief gehen so, ne? Klar kann schief gehen, aber erstens trifft das vielleicht nicht unbedingt für alle Punkte vor in so einem dicken Paket ähm und manchmal gibt's ja auch,
sehr positive Entwicklung, wie wir das mit der DSGVO gesehen haben.
Okay, dann lass uns mal weitergehen, was dieser Digital Service Act noch so abdeckt, was ihr so bei im Blick habt. An guten wie im Schlechten.
Ja ähm also es gibt einen weiteren Punkt, der der der gut ist ähm oder die vielleicht zwei Punkte, die ich zusammen nennen kann, weil das der gleiche Artikel ist, den das Parlament da reingeschrieben hat und hier wieder das Parlament sind, hier die Good Guys gewesen. Die haben gesagt, ey, wenn wir schon ein Gesetz machen,
so ne
Digitale Dienste ähm sollten wir nicht einfach die Gelegenheit nutzen und hier noch mal ein paar Schutzvorschriften reinschreiben für Nutzerinnen und Nutzer, die gesagt, hey, es gibt ja immer wieder Angriffe, ist vielleicht hier im Podcast auch schon mal genannt worden, immer wieder Angriffe gegen Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung.
Also gegen sichere Messenger zum Beispiel wie wie und und
Dami hat gesagt, hey, lass uns doch reinschreiben. In Zukunft Mitgliedsstaaten ist es nicht mehr erlaubt in der EU
irgendwelche Gesetze zu erlassen, die diese Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln und irgendwie unterminieren.
Full Pop Punkt. Das ist einfach der Satz. Ähm sehr sehr mächtig, wirkungsmächtig, wenn so was in Kraft treten würde, wäre das total super. Ähm und äh damit verbunden ganz ähnliches Thema äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung gleicher Artikel als Parlament einfach reingeschrieben.
Mitgliedsstaaten ist es in Zukunft verboten Gesetze zur anlasslosen Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu erlassen.
Ähm ich wir meinen bei Etri, das ist sowieso schon aktuelle Rechtssprechung des europäischen Gerichtshofs. Insofern ähm äh
ja haben wir das eigentlich schon, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem cool
das einfach nochmal schwarz auf weiß ins Gesetz reinzuschreiben und klarzumachen hier das ist wirklich das was auch von politischer Ebene gewollt ist.
Denkst du, das hat eine Chance im im Rat auch durchzukommen, weil da sind ja nun die Staaten schon seit Jahr und Tag immer total in im im Durchlauferhitzermodus gewesen und äh haben eigentlich.
Würde ich auch ein großes Fragezeichen dran machen. Ob das drin bleibt? Die Frage ist halt dann am Schluss, so jetzt diese Verhandlungen, die müssen sich halt einigen auf ein Kompromiss. Da ist eine Menge Kuhhandel dabei. Das heißt, kann gut sein, dass dann die Mitgliedsstaaten sagen, hey liebes Parlament,
okay, ihr wollt das Verbot von Tracking-Werbung? Cookie-Banner und so, kriegt ihr aber nur, wenn wir halt den Kram für die Vorratszahl ansprechen und die Verschlüsselung.
Aber ist es bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt nicht besonders knifflig, jetzt wo das EUGH sich nun wirklich mehrfach wiederholt und nachdrücklich gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgesprochen hat.
Ja, das scheint die Mitgliedsstaaten nicht davon abzuhalten, es immer wieder zu probieren.
Kenne ihn nicht. Was was habe ich mit dem Gericht zu tun? Ja okay hm naja gut.
Aber ich will auch nicht nur ein Loblied auf den DSA singen. Es gibt auch Dinge, wo wir gesagt haben, so oh autsch, ähm das hätte nicht passieren dürfen. Ähm.
Können ja vielleicht erstmal die positiven Sachen mal abräumen.
Zumindest erstmal die Illusion erzeugen. Es wäre alles super.
Ja das ist so ein so ein Cliffhanger.
Verkauf das mal richtig. Komm, DSA, komm, komm. Der geilste Scheiß.
Habe ja am Anfang schon mal erwähnt, dass das äh dass also die Kommission da aus den aus den Fehlern in Deutschland auch was gelernt hat ähm und in der Tat ist das also so, dass dass der DSA jetzt diese
Löschfristen nicht vorschreibt, sondern stattdessen sagt,
Online-Plattformen müssen ein äh sogenanntes ähm Notifizierungssystem anbieten. Viele von denen machen das auch schon, also die Möglichkeit für Nutzerinnen und Nutzer ähm äh Inhalte zu.
Ja zu zu flarken und zu sagen, hey Moment, das ist doch möglicherweise illegal.
Also Löschfristen jetzt von illegalen Posts. Das meinst du jetzt, ne? Also jemand schreibt irgendwie was ganz Böses.
Wie wie der Holocaust war böse.
Holocaust-Überlebenden waren böse. Die haben jetzt.
Ja genau. Nee, also.
Linksextreme Sachen gehen gar nicht.
Genau, also sagen wir mal so, Hasskommentare, bla, bla, äh halt das, wo ja auch das Netzwerk äh Durchsetzungsgesetz angesetzt hat, so was erlaube, Plattformen. Ähm und dann war halt lange Zeit die Diskussion, wie wie regelt man das jetzt und Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz sagt ja, irgendwie muss hier innerhalb von so und so viele Stunden
muss das dann verschwunden sein, was natürlich dann grade für kleinere Plattformen einen extremen Druck und Personalaufwand erzeugt.
Ja
Und die Idee dahinter ist immer die Gleiche. Wie wie können wir diesen äh Druck, das ist ganz ganz klar politisch gewollt. Wir wollen den Druck aufbauen ähm und die Idee war halt zu sagen, man baut diesen Druck auf, indem man sagt, wenn ihr das dann nicht löscht,
Dann seid ihr am Schluss als Plattform haftbar zu machen für diese Inhalte, wie als wenn das eure Inhalte wären.
Und und das ist natürlich ein rechtliches Risiko, was eine Plattform nicht eingehen kann und nicht will. Ähm insofern
daher eben auch dann das Risiko, dass das zu viel löschen ist quasi von von eigentlich legitimen, von eigentlich legalen Inhalten.
Und da sagt der DSA jetzt halt, okay, ähm Notifizierungssystem ja.
Das muss transparent sein, es muss durchgängig funktionieren, da muss es eine Antwort drauf geben auch, dass es ja heute häufig das Problem. Man kann zwar Sachen irgendwie auf Twitter
irgendwie
sich beschweren, dass da irgendwas ist, was was man glaubt, was Illegales, aber man kriegt halt nie eine Antwort. Ähm und äh man weiß nie, was damit eigentlich passiert. Das wäre dann unter dem DSA nicht mehr möglich. Ähm es muss die Möglichkeit geben für Nutzerinnen, Nutzer
menschliche Gesprächspartnerinnen und Gesprächspartner bei den Plattformen zu erreichen, wenn solche Beschwerden diskutiert werden
und und das ist so die die letzte Etappe, wenn man so ein so eine so ein Fler-ging von möglicherweise illegalen Inhalten macht und mit dem Ergebnis, mit der Entscheidung der Plattform dazu nicht zufrieden ist
Muss man nicht mehr gleich vor Gericht ziehen, denn das können sich die meisten Leute nicht leisten, ähm sondern es würde dann einen
ein vorgeschriebenen, erstmal einen internen äh interne Beschwerdemmechanismus bei der Plattform geben und wenn der auch nicht hilft
Gibt es ein äh ein Streitschlichtungsmechanismus äh zu dem die Plattformen verpflichtet sind
teilzunehmen aktiv und auch am Teil der Kosten zu tragen.
Und äh und dieser Streitschlichtungsmechanismus, das sind wirklich muss man sich vorstellen, also
ja so Subgerichte oder quasi Quasi-Gerichte, die eingerichtet sind mit mit unabhängigen Expertinnen und Experten, Juristinnen und Juristen, die äh die solche ähm Entscheidungen dann überprüfen und
was diese Streitschlichtungsmechanismen dann sagen, ist tatsächlich dann auch bindend für die Plattform. So sieht es der DSA vor.
Mhm. Okay.
Also insgesamt die Sache hat eben der Versuch zu sagen, ähm dieses System zu verbessern, ähm sodass das am Schluss wirklich funktioniert, ohne aber
Anreize für die Plattform zu schaffen, äh mehr äh mehr Inhalte zu löschen als eigentlich wirklich illegal sind. Denn man muss halt auch realistischerweise sehen, viel von dem, was so geflaggt wird von Nuzeret und Nutzern.
Ist halt einfach nicht illegal, sondern dass die Leute flagen halt Sachen, weil sie die doof finden oder weil's irgendwie äh anderer Meinung sind oder oder weil sie denen diejenigen, die Personen, die das gepostet hassen, ähm aber das ist natürlich kein Grund ähm dann äh
System zu missbrauchen, um halt unliebsame Inhalte irgendwie zu entfernen.
Ja
Genau, ja jetzt ist halt dieser Missbrauchsproblematik war ja äh auch beim letzten immer immer schon so das Thema von Anfang an, dass das halt einfach missbraucht wird, um dann irgendwie
Leute online äh wegzumobben und das sieht man ja auch regelmäßig diese Versuche und teilweise ist es ja auch erfolgreich. Allright.
Du denn den Eindruck ähm
bei diesen Sachen äh wenn du noch eine pro äh Sache hast, dann kannst du die gleich ähm äh noch nennen, aber wir hatten jetzt hier so Trekking äh Werbung. Okay, da da werden die Plattformen was dagegen haben, Schutz von Ende zu Ende-Verschlüsselung vielleicht eher nicht.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung wahrscheinlich auch eher nicht und dieses Notifizierungssystem würde ich sagen ist jetzt auch nicht gerade unbedingt etwas, was bei den Plattformen auf äh sehr viel Gegenwehr stoßen sollte im Vergleich zu dem, wie es jetzt ist, oder?
Äh nee, da haben wir jetzt auch nicht besonders viel Beschwerde gehört. Also vielleicht die kleinen Plattformen irgendwie äh wollen sich da vielleicht irgendwie rauslösen. Ähm aber es gibt auch eine Ausnahmeregelung für kleine und ganz häufig für Mikro-Unternehmen und so was.
Also ich glaube das ist insgesamt eher unstreitig. Ich glaube was wirklich äh auf auf viel viel Gegenwehr gestoßen hat, überraschend viel Gegenwehr.
Vielleicht sollte ich sagen, eigentlich nicht überraschend viel Gegenwehr, verständlich viel Gegenwehr äh ist tatsächlich das Verbot von Tracking-Werbung. Ähm da gab's eine riesige Lobby-Kampagne dagegen von äh von Seiten Facebook und äh den Industrieverbänden, die die dort unterhalten.
Ja, das tut ihnen richtig weh. Das haben wir ja jetzt ja gerade gesehen mit Facebook, die mal soeben äh.
Bekannt geben mussten, dass sie das mal so locker zehn Milliarden Dollar kostet, dass irgendwie allein Apple aufm iPhone mal ein bisschen die Schotten dicht gemacht hat und sie generell äh natürlich auch äh gerade ein bisschen wackelig dastehen und schwuppdiwupp,
25 Prozent ihres Aktienwerts na? Wie nachhaltig das ist muss man nochmal sehen aber das zeigt auf jeden Fall dass sie da was zu befürchten haben.
Also sonst noch ein positiver Aspekte oder neutrale vielleicht.
Ah es gibt viele kleine Details irgendwie die hier und da die Dinge verbessern ähm aber ich glaube so im Großen und Ganzen, das waren so die wichtigsten Punkte, die sich auch tatsächlich direkt äh glaube ich bemerkbar machen werden für die Nutzerinnen.
Also positiv bemerkbar machen aus eurer Perspektive. Mhm. Aber gibt bestimmt auch noch ein paar, die gefallen dir nicht so gut.
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall und da das ist wirklich dann auch frustrierend. Ähm es gibt zum Beispiel eine,
einen Artikel, der neu eingefügt worden ist vom Parlament und ich glaube das ist sogar ein Vorschlag der ursprünglich auf äh ein äh einen Änderungsantrag der Grünen im Europäischen Parlament zurückgeht und zwar äh haben die sich gesagt, hey wir wollen die Gelegenheit nutzen und
Opfer von sogenanntem Revenchor besser schützen, also von äh Inhalten pornografischen Inhalten, die ohne,
Zustimmung der abgebildeten Personen meistens der weiblichen Person aber zum Teil auch männlichen Personen ähm,
äh hochgeladen und zu öffentlich gemacht werden. Ähm häufig als Racheakt in Beziehungen oder ähnlichen Situationen.
Und das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem und da leiden natürlich die entsprechenden, die Opfer entsprechend auch stark drunter. Ähm
und den Vorschlag, der da aber vorgelegt worden ist, sieht unter anderem vor, dass Plattformen, die speziell jetzt Pornografie ähm auf Pornografie spezialisiert sind, also Sachen wie
Habe zum Beispiel, dass die dazu verpflichtet sind, jeden Uploader und jede Uploaderin mit einer Handynummer zu identifizieren.
Alle wissen, dass Handynummern in Europa nicht mehr anonym sind, sondern man muss seine seinen Ausweis vorzeigen, wer meine Handynummer will, eine SIM-Karte.
Ähm und das würde bedeuten, dass sich eben bei den Pornoplattformen äh eine
gigantische Sammlung von identifizierbaren Daten äh anhäufen würde, verknüpft mit den entsprechenden natürlich Pornovideos, die da hochgeladen werden.
Und da haben wir eben die Alarmglocke bekommen, vor allem von Organisationen auch, die die Rechte von Sexarbeiterinnen und Sexarbeitern vertreten und gesagt, das ist ein.
Akzeptables Risiko, denn das sind.
Sind Menschen die häufig sowieso schon stigmatisiert sind und wenn solche Daten dann an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen sei es durch einen Hackerangriff oder sei es durch einen äh anderweitig geartetes äh äh Datenleck
oder eben auch an die Behörden natürlich gehen. Ähm da gibt's natürlich dann Zugriffsrechte für Strafverfolgungsbehörden in allen europäischen Ländern, dass das also ein ein ein gigantisches Risiko ist. Ähm,
und sicherlich als als Nebeneffekt auch ist schafft das natürlich auch im Präzedenzfall
gegen Anonymität im Netz, also für eine gesetzliche Vorschrift der Identifizierung von
Plattformnutzerinnen und Plattformnutzern und wenn das erstmal Schule macht, dann sehen wir natürlich sofort auch gleich äh das Risiko, dass äh dass irgendwann mal jemand da auf die Idee kommt, in der Europäischen Kommission zu sagen, hey, das könnten wir ja eigentlich auch für andere Plattformen mal machen.
Das bei Pirat Bay dann auch angeben muss, wenn man da einen Torwart äh was ich was ich ähm.
Also diese Sache mit dem Revention ist natürlich so ein total
unappetitliches Thema, ne? Also das ist irgendwie alles äußerst äußerst unschöner Phänomenbereich und ähm wir haben ja hier auch das Thema behandelt
das ein oder andere Mal ja in insbesondere als es dann um so diese Festivalduschen geht, wo dann da diese äh Spannervideos äh veröffentlicht werden und
also ein ein nicht endender Kampf ist diese diese Materialien da wieder aus dem Netz zu schaffen und ähm.
Dann ja auch immer quasi von diesen Plattformenbetreibern gesagt wird, ja das ist ja nur so
dargestellt, als würde die Person das nicht wissen. In Wirklichkeit hat die sich ja selber gefilmt oder sonstiges, ne? Und ich frage mich immer, ob man nicht ähm ich meine.
Ob man nicht einfach verlangen müsste, dass das den Betreibern ein Video vorliegt, in dem die gezeigt
Person irgendwie klar zu erkennen gibt, ich bin hier gerade mit dem was hier passiert einvereinverstanden und das einmal zu Beginn sagt und auch zum Ende noch einmal sagt ich bin damit einverstanden ja was ja immer noch nicht reichen würde weil
sie könnte dieses Einverständnis ja auch widerrufen. Also es ist jetzt irgendwie kein,
kein äh keinen zu Ende gedachter Gedanke, ja aber ähm irgendeine Form von.
Nachvollziehbarkeit dieser Straftaten möchte man ja schon haben,
und gleichzeitig ist das wieder so eine Situation, wo sämtliche Vorschläge, die dann natürlich auch ähm.
Ähm ja auf einer Welle der Empörung, der berechtigten Empörung reiten äh das Risiko haben, denn das Kind mit dem Bade äh äh schütten, ne. Das
ich finde das immer sehr schwierig, solchen äh bei solchen Themen mit einem ausgewogenen Gegenvorschlag.
Ähm ja, aufzutreten
weil der natürlich auch nicht so einfach zu finden ist. Und weil man natürlich in dem Moment, wo man sagt, hör mal, das scheint hier aber ein Problem zu sein, sofort dastehen und sagt, wollt ihr den Missbrauch und die Retraumatisierung
dieser betroffenen Person natürlich nicht. Ja, aber wir wollen natürlich auch nicht, dass die.
Ja Vernichtung des freien Internets oder des des komplette Stigmatisieren von sämtlichen Leuten, die diese Plattform im in einem legitimen Rahmen nutzen. Habt ihr da schon
kannst du da in dem Stand der Debatte mal sagen, was da bisher so der der sainst, der Vorschlag zu sein scheint?
Ja, also es gibt der der Artikel, der da eingereicht wurde, hat neben dieser Verpflichtung zur Identifikation ähm auch noch zwei weitere Paragraphen und die machen viel Sinn. Also da geht's um die Frage, wie schnell müssen Plattformen reagieren, wenn etwas,
Geflaggt wird, auch das ist ja aktuell das Problem, dass wenn sich also eine betroffene Person wirklich,
beschwert, dass dann eben häufig lange Zeit erstmal nichts passiert und die Plattformen da nicht wirklich ansprechbar sind. Ähm und äh und mal ganz ehrlich, mal dafür ist ja eigentlich auch das vorhin schon diskutierte äh ähm Notifizierungssystem eigentlich da.
Das da geht's ja genau darum, dass es eben eine schnelle und,
nachvollziehbare Möglichkeit gibt eben zu sagen, hier das ist das ist das das dürfte nicht online sein, ähm das ist illegal. Äh bitte nehmt das runter,
und ähm und hier kann man tatsächlich auch für so eine spezielle Art von Inhalten auch gerne noch mal einen Schritt weitergehen, denn jetzt muss man halt auch klar sagen, jetzt bei pornografischen ähm Inhalten jetzt mal, sage ich mal so, Videos zum Beispiel, da ist es ja auch.
Ist jetzt der Eingriff in das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung,
sage ich mal, niedriger anzusetzen, als wenn man's jetzt um politische Debatten in sozialen Netzwerken geht zum Beispiel. Also wir haben da mal aus Versehen ein Video zu viel äh suspendiert wird, dann ist das vielleicht nicht ganz so dramatisch, wenn man das dann ein paar Tage später wieder online stellt, nachdem man den Sachverhalt geklärt hat. Aber dazu müssten die Plattformen natürlich eben auch entsprechend in Ressourcen
investieren, müssen äh Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter haben, die sich um diese Sachen kümmern und in in in angemessenem Rahmen darauf halt reagieren können.
Aber ich glaube am Schluss wird es ähm wie du vielleicht auch schon darauf hingewiesen hast mit mit deinem mit deinem Vorschlag, dass da das wird ein ein Bündel an Maßnahmen sein, eine Kombination an Maßnahmen, die dann versucht hoffentlich
Problem, ähm was ja ein ernstzunehmendes wirklich schwerwiegendes äh Problem ist
einigermaßen abzufangen und in den Griff zu kriegen, eine hundertprozentige Lösung gibt es nicht,
Es gibt aber auch mit der Identifizierungspflicht ist das keine hundertprozentige Lösung. Denn nur weil man da jetzt eine Telefonnummer angeben muss, heißt es ja nicht, dass irgendein ein bösartiger Mensch dann nicht doch
solche Inhalte hochlädt am Schluss. Ähm sei es mit einer geklauten Telefonnummer oder ganz ehrlich,
mit der Telefonnummer des Partners den man da schädigen will. Also das ist ja durchaus dann auch möglich.
Also diese Telefonnummernbindung, das sollte man nur an dieser Stelle natürlich auch nochmal sagen, das ist äh genau für all jenen ein Problem oder der der davon sind all jene betroffen, die nicht.
Fünf bis zehn Minuten Aufwand betreiben wollen um sich mal eben eine anonyme Telefonnummer zu organisieren, ja. Also die äh die zu bekommen, auch SIM-Karten oder sonstiges, ist ja nun wirklich
eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem und ähm natürlich aber die meisten Menschen
denken dann, ah ja, ich habe ja hier nichts zu verbergen, also mache ich das mal und das sind dann natürlich diejenigen, die dann später im Identity League drin hängen oder die äh und äh dann entsprechende Belästigungen erfahren oder die den sonstiger
misst angedeiht und den dann einfach die Betroffenen dieser Einschränkung und über Erfassung sind ähm
während der das tatsächliche Ziel der Strafverfolgung oder Identifizierbarkeit von denjenigen, die wissentlich ähm.
Tja äh hier die Rechte anderer verletzten äh bei dem Ziel äh nicht wirklich näher kommt, ne.
So so ähnlich sehen wir das auch und wir hoffen sehr, dass das jetzt am Schluss nicht im finalen Gesetz mit drinbleibt. Ähm die Mitgliedsstaaten haben diese Regelung nicht in ihrer Position. Muss man halt schauen, wie der Kuhhandel da ausgeht.
Dann sagt er noch mal, was noch so problematisch ist aus eurer Perspektive.
Es gibt einen Punkt, den wir für sehr sehr wirkmächtig gehalten haben und den wir weiterhin für sehr sehr wichtig halten, der aber es weder in die Position des Europäischen Parlamentes noch in die Position
Ähm äh das der der Mitgliedsstaaten reingeschaffen hat und zwar äh ist das äh eine Regelung, die es,
möglich gemacht hätte für Nutzerinnen und Nutzerinnenutzer äh auf in einem sozialen Netzwerk zum Beispiel äh ein
ein Vorschlagsalgorithmus oder ein Sortieralgorithmus zu benutzen von Drittanbietern.
Aktuell ist ja so, wenn man auf Facebook geht äh oder auf YouTube, dann die Inhalte, die man da vorgeschlagen kriegt in seiner Timeline oder das, was man als Nächstes gucken soll auf YouTube. Das kommt halt von den Unternehmen selbst und ist damit getrieben durch,
die,
ähm durch die ja kommerziellen Interessen der Plattformen, kommerzielles Interesse ist. Ich will, dass du so langwierig auf der Plattform bleibst, so viel wie möglich klickst und Daten über dich gibst äh und dir Werbung bei uns anschaust. Ähm und das äh
das erzählen die Plattformen aktuell häufig damit, dass sie uns Nutzerinnen, Nutzern, eben vor allem.
Skandalisierende Inhalte zeigen. Sachen, die uns frustrieren, nerven, die uns am Bildschirm kleben lassen. Ähm nicht unbedingt Dinge, die wir wirklich gerne sehen wollen,
Es gibt zurück auf grad auf YouTube zu diesen klassischen Rabbit Hole äh Effekt der der glaube ich ganz gut untersucht ist wissenschaftlich auch
wo Menschen eben egal was sie als erstes suchen, wenn sie immer den den Such den Vorschlägen dann von von YouTube äh folgen, dann irgendwie in in einem Rechtsradikalen oder ähm äh oder so ein Anti-Wachs äh Querdenker Loch quasi landen.
Was wollen oder nicht, egal mit welchem Thema man beginnt. Einfach weil das ist, was die Leute halt am am am Klicken hält
Und hier war eben der die Idee zu sagen und das ist äh gibt's eine ganze Reihe an Expertinnen und Experten, die das ausgearbeitet und vorgeschlagen haben zu sagen, hey, sollten wir den Leuten nicht die Möglichkeit geben, so eine Plattform zu nutzen, aber selbst zu entscheiden?
Was sie eigentlich sehen wollen. Da gibt's auch schon ganz gute Beispiele für und zwar nicht so sehr auf jetzt Plattformen wie YouTube und Facebook, denn die sind sehr sehr geschlossen. Da kann man von Drittanbietern nicht so viel
mitmachen aber Twitter ist ein kleines bisschen offener und es gibt ein ein ein Startup in in den USA äh die heißt eine Block Party äh die haben ein ein Plug-in quasi für Twitter ähm äh entwickelt
was speziell darauf es abzielt für.
Belästigung.
Ja, für für Online-Belästigung quasi. Ähm äh zu schützen. Ähm also das ist, wir haben einen Algorithmus entwickelt, der darauf spezialisiert ist. Ähm so Online-Belästigungen, vor allem sexuelle Belästigungen zu erkennen äh und die schmeißen das dann in so einen separaten
Ordner, da kann man das muss man sich das nicht angucken, kriegt man gar nicht zu Gesicht, dann kann man noch irgendwie eine Freundin oder Freund designieren und kann sagen, hey, kannst du da hin und wieder mal reinschauen, dass da keine Fails-Positives irgendwie drin sind? Ähm und äh ohne, dass man sich selbst quasi die diese diese
ja doch einen sehr negativen Inhalte dann dann zu Gemüte führen muss.
Und so was geht aber natürlich nur, wenn man ein gewisses Level an vertikaler, wir nennen das Interoperabilität
äh hat äh für oder ja auf diesen Plattformen, also die Möglichkeit für Drittanbietern über APIs oder oder offene Standards äh diese Inhalte eben auch für andere Art und Weise zu sortieren.
Als das jetzt die die Plattform machen würden. Ähm und so eine Verpflichtung für Interoporabilität, für Drittanbieter.
Besonders jetzt für diese Sortier- und Rankingalgorithmen das hätte es wunderbar in den in den DSA reingepasst. Ähm aber es ist natürlich ein sehr technisches Thema.
Sowas zu erklären. Jemanden, der nicht so genau weiß, was Interoperabilität,
ist, was der Unterschied zwischen einer geschlossenen Zentralisiertenplattform ist und einer offenen, was eine API ist. Das ist gar nicht so einfach, das in diese politische Debatte irgendwie unter zu
zu bringen. Ähm insofern, also das ist jetzt leider nicht mit reingekommen. Da sind wir sehr enttäuscht, weil wir uns wirklich davon im großen großen Sprung
erhofft haben für den für den Schutz äh von Menschen vor Inhalten, die sie eigentlich gar nicht sehen wollen
inklusive natürlich auch illegalen Inhalten, ähm ohne, dass da jetzt immer die Löschpolizei gleich hinterher muss.
In welchem Ausschuss wird nochmal der DSA äh behandelt?
Er wird im Verbraucherschutzausschuss verhandelt.
Wer ist da die Berichterstatterin?
Die Berichterstatterin ist Crystal Schalldemose, eine dänische Sozialdemokratin, ähm die sich in der Vergangenheit nicht so sehr mit Digitalthemen hervorgetan hatte, die sich aber erstaunlich schnell in die Thematik eingearbeitet hat in ihrem Job.
Mhm. Okay, also die ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so schlecht macht da, Meinung nach.
Nee, die hat's nicht hat's nicht schlecht gemacht. Insgesamt äh handelt sich auch eine beschränkte Macht, sage ich mal,
muss hängt aber auch von den von den Abstimmungsverhältnissen dann ab aber jetzt gerade so diese sehr technischen Themen wie diese Interoprabilität ähm da sind wir einfach äh da sind wir einfach äh gegen gegen ja gegen Wände gelaufen und ähm
Haben da Schwierigkeiten gehabt und es gab entsprechende Änderungsanträge von kleineren Parteien, von den Grünen, von den Linken, äh im im Parlament, um so was einzuführen, aber die haben am Ende keine Mehrheit bekommen. Da war einfach dann die die große konservative Mehrheit im europäischen Parlament mit den Liberalen zusammen zu zu stark dagegen.
Ja, ist auch wirklich sagen wir mal, ist aber auch wirklich ein komplexes.
Das macht auch wirklich nochmal so ein komplexes Unterthema auf in einem ohnehin schon sehr komplexen Thema. Vielleicht ist dafür die Zeit auch noch noch nicht reif. Aber lasst uns bei den Sachen bleiben, die da noch konkreter verhandelt äh werden. Was sollten wir noch.
Sehen, wenn man auf den DSA schaut.
Ja, was glaube ich sehr sehr spannend zu betrachten wird, ist die Frage der Rechtsdurchsetzung. Wenn das alles einmal in Kraft getreten ist, die Frage wird das denn eigentlich.
Äh geht da dann die Polizei regelmäßig zu den Plattformen hin oder zu den Nutzerinnen und Nutzern oder ist das dann eher so wie bei der beim Datenschutzgesetz der DSGVO ähm das dann irgendwie doch jeder macht was er will und am Schluss guckt da keiner mehr so genau drauf. Ähm,
und äh und da gab's eben auch eine lange Diskussion darüber, wie die Durchsetzung genau stattfinden soll und zwar nicht so sehr die Frage, wie hoch sind die Strafen, die jetzt ein Unternehmen bei bei äh Nichtbeachtung des DSA zahlen muss, sondern mehr.
Äh eine Debatte darüber, ähm welche Aufsichtsbehörde da zuständig sein soll, das durchzusetzen.
Da haben die Mitgliedsstaaten sehr stark natürlich dafür geworben, äh dass das auf Mitgliedsstaaten Ebene stattfindet, ähnlich wie das bei der DSGVO ja auch der Fall ist. Da gibt nicht jeder jeder Mitgliedsstaat in der EU hat seine eigene Datenschutzbehörde in Deutschland haben wir es sogar jedes Bundesland seine eigene Datenschutzbehörde noch
Ähm und äh und das zersplittert natürlich die Durchsetzung am Schluss entsprechend, weil jede Datenschutzbehörde einzeln,
dann halt auch nur auf eine bestimmte begrenzte Menge an Ressourcen zurückgreifen kann.
Oder auf begrenzte Menge an an an Durchsetzungswillen, wie man das in äh Irland sieht.
Genau, genau. Daher gibt's natürlich dann eben auch gleichzeitig dann natürlich das Risiko, dass das das captorings durch die Unternehmen und ähm und da hat die Kommission in der Tat auch dann versucht rauszulernen und haben gesagt, wie können wir's besser machen? Die haben also einen
Modell vorgeschlagen und gesagt, lass uns doch die kleinen Fälle auf lokaler Ebene bearbeiten. Kann jeder Mitgliedsstaat seine Behörde haben. Ähm die nennen sich im DSA
Services, Coordinators äh oder die ACs.
Und äh und darüber hinaus soll es aber trotzdem auch für die Europäische Kommission auf europäischer Ebene die Macht geben für große Fälle, also grenzüberschreitende Fälle, äh Fälle, wo die Kommission sagt, oh
Müsste man eigentlich aktiv werden, aber.
Die nationale Behörde tut's nicht, hallo Irland. Ähm so also für solche Fälle sollte die Kommission dann die Macht haben, da einzusprengen. Das war so die Idee dahinter.
Also so eine Schremsklausel.
Genau, man könnte das auch eine Schremsklausel ne.
Dann wir waren da auch im Prinzip ähm und ne full disclosia, Max Schrems mit Neub ist ja Mitglied auch bei Edri.
Ähm wir sind auch voll dafür gewesen und fanden das eine gute Idee da zu sagen, hey, dass wir da einfach noch mal eine eine eine stärkere Ebene einfügen. Du musst bedenken, das sind ja hier ein Forcement, das das ist ja das
mit die mächtigsten Unternehmen, die die Erde je gesehen hat. Ähm und natürlich muss man sich da als Behörde stark aufstellen. Das ist das ist ganz klar. Ähm wo wir uns große Sorgen gemacht haben und auch immer noch machen, ist, dass
Während die nationalen Behörden genau wie bei der Datenschutz auch unabhängige Behörden sind, ist die Europäische Kommission natürlich.
Eher na ja halt eine politische Institution
die Kommissare, die Kommissare bis hoch zur Kommissionspräsidentin sind ja politisch ausgewählte Figuren, häufig mit politischer Vergangenheit und nicht unabhängige Rechtsdurchsetzungsbehörden.
Äh Regulierungsbehörden und diese Doppelrolle in der Kommission, die sehen wir kritisch, weil wir eben weil bisher nicht klar ist, wer in der Kommission wird denn diesen Job dann eigentlich übernehmen.
Das einfach dann irgendeine
Unterabteilung, die dann unter dem Kommissar Breton sitzt, der für die Digitalpolitik zuständig ist, ähm der als Franzose aber auch eng eng mit der französischen Regierung verbandelt ist und damit seine eigenen politischen Interessen hat. Ähm oder wird das dann irgendwas so
ja semi-unabhängiges und und diese Unsicherheit, die hätten wir eigentlich gerne geklärt jetzt im Gesetz. Ähm es gab in der Tat auch den Vorschlag ähm zu sagen, könnte man nicht eine Komplett unabhängige
Behörde auf europäischer Ebene schaffen. Ähm das das wäre eigentlich für uns die präferierte Lösung gewesen, aber da hat sich politisch niemand dann getraut.
Bis wir die aufgebaut haben und da die Ressourcen uns aus dem großen europäischen Budget rausgeschnitten haben, ähm werden noch mal ein paar Jahre ins Land gegangen. So lange können wir nicht warten. Ähm.
Könnte man ja zumindest als Tradition machen, ne. Also ich meine, es gibt ja auch eine europäische Datenschutzbehörde, die dann eben ne,
potentiell, zumindest die Datenschutzfragen auch äh übernehmen kann.
Genauso könnte man das ja bei der Dienste Regulierung auch machen und wenn man sagt OK ja die gibt's aber nicht die Bürde müssen wir alles aufbauen kann man ja sagen ja okay in vier Jahren äh ist dann vielleicht soweit.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen unsere positive Lesart in der Geschichte, dass wir sagen, na gut, lass uns erst mal,
auf europäischer Ebene des NVR haben bei der Kommission, guck mal, wie das funktioniert, wenn sich herausstellt, die ist nicht unabhängig, dann machen wir in vier, fünf Jahren nochmal einen neuen Anlauf und gucken, ob wir das nicht ausgliedern können irgendwie. Aber zumindest haben wir's dann auf europäischer Ebene
etabliert. Ähm das ist sicherlich, so kann man's sicherlich sehen. Auch wenn es insgesamt ja ähm uns doch ein bisschen mulmig bei der Sache ist, der Kommission da so viel Macht in die Hand zu geben.
Ja. Okay, aber spielt es sich dann schon mal zentralisiert ab und ist nicht wieder so ein Nebenkriegsschauplatz irgendwo in Irland äh.
Wo einfach klar ist, da wird dann vor allem im Kontext irischen Wirtschaftsinteresses,
gearbeitet, also den Eindruck macht es ja nun wirklich deutlich, ne. Ähm das kann ja sich dann wiederum die Europäische Kommission nicht leisten. Sondern die muss ja dann eigentlich auch,
Selbst als Kommission, selbst wenn sie jetzt äh da äh unter Politikverdacht steht ähm,
muss sie ja dann zumindest auch für alle entscheiden, ne. Also kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das auch eine Verbesserung ist.
Ja.
Mhm, okay. Noch was?
Für den DSA glaube ich war's das. Also das ist ähm ist glaube ich schon ein ganz schöner Batzen.
Okay. Gut ähm.
Vielleicht nochmal so zur Timeline, äh wo steht
der DSA gerade und wo wie wie ist da jetzt sozusagen der Zeitrahmen gerade? Also wann soll da was beschlossen werden? Wann geht es vom Parlament.
Also wann soll's vom Parlament beschlossen werden, der Vorschlag, wann geht das quasi in die Verhandlungsrunde mit Kommission und Rat.
Aktuell ist der Stand, dass sowohl das Europäische Parlament ähm als auch der Rat mit den Mitgliedsstaaten und das gilt natürlich sowohl für den DSA als auch für den DMA, den Digital Markets Eck, die sind da parallel in ihrem Prozess
die haben jeweils ihre Position festgelegt. Wir wissen also, dass wir das Parlament, das will der Rat und seit Anfang des Jahres sitzen die jetzt mehrmals
wöchentlich in Arbeitsgruppen zusammen und versuchen Kompromisse zu verhandeln. Ähm in solchen komplexen Gesetzen dauert so was üblicherweise.
Halbes Jahr manchmal ein Jahr, je nachdem wie schnell die sich halt einigen können und wie groß der politische Wille dahinter ist
In diesem Fall allerdings haben alle Beteiligten angekündigt, dass sie das sehr viel schneller
über die Bühne bringen wollen. Ähm das hat in erster Linie politische Gründe. Ähm es ist ähm öffentlich bekannt, dass der
Französische Präsident Macron sehr gerne den den DSA und den DMA als ähm
als als einer Präsenz im persönlichen Erfolg im Wahlkampf äh äh benutzen will. Die Franzosen ähm wählen im äh April äh einen neuen Präsidenten oder neue Präsidentin und ähm.
Und da möchtet ihr das gerne äh ja verwenden. Frankreich hat aktuell die Ratspräsidentschaft inne, die rotiert immer alle sechs Monate und in diesem Rahmen will Frankreich sich da gerne produzieren. Deswegen ist da der große politische Druck. Wir wollen das gerne vor den Wahlen in Frankreich
über die Bühne kriegen, also idealerweise im März. Ich persönlich habe keine Idee, wie die das schaffen wollen, äh innerhalb.
Okay, das wäre jetzt meine Frage, ja.
Bleiben noch acht acht Wochen übrig. Ähm ich sehe das nicht. Ähm aber gut, ich lasse mich auch gerne überraschen. Ich habe nichts dagegen, wenn die das früh fertig machen, dann kann ich nämlich endlich mal Urlaub nehmen.
Immer diese Partikular-Interessen. Ich bitte dich.
Absolut.
Mhm. Linus, hast du noch? Was zum DS.
Nö, dann gucken wir uns den DMA an, oder?
Ja, gerne. So, ja genau, Digital Markus Act, also die Dinger werden ja jetzt immer in einem Atemzug genannt.
Ähm aus gutem Grund, weil sie ja gemeinsam auch angeschoben werden
Wenn jetzt beim Digital Services Act der Fokus quasi jetzt hier auf den Dienstleistungen und wie die durchzuführen sind und unter welchen Bedingungen äh sind, geht's beim Market Act,
Was genau, also das ist dann eher also wie ist das getrennt sozusagen, wie wie definiert sich das anders.
Es gibt sehr inhaltliche Trennung und es gibt eine Trennung anhand des Anwendungsbereiches. Die inhaltliche Trennung oder Zielsetzung ist beim Digital Market Act äh eher Richtung Wettbewerbspolitik.
Ähm also die Anerkennung steckt dahinter, dass aktuell
des Wettbewerbs Recht auf europäischer Ebene zwar sehr mächtig ist, aber in äh in der Digitalwirtschaft häufig zu langsam.
Die Europäische Kommission in einem Wettbewerbsfall und da gab's jetzt schon einige sehr äh sehr in der Öffentlichkeit breit diskutierte von Microsoft mit seinem.
Das Windows Media Players in den Neunzigern, bis aktuell die Fälle gegen Google wegen Selbstbeurteilung der Google
Shoppingsuche und solche Sachen. Also diese Fälle finden zwar alle statt
aber bis die entschieden sind ähm hat sich der Markt häufig schon zementiert und die möglichen Wettbewerber sind dann in bis dahin schon längst rausgeflogen oder mussten aufgeben oder wurden aufgekauft,
oder was auch immer. Insofern, das war so, ist so ein bisschen die Ausgangslage und dann haben äh hat die EU halt gesagt, okay, müssten wir diese Entscheidungen nicht verschnälern im Prinzip äh und sagen ähm wir.
Müssen in die nicht mehr in jeder einzelnen Entscheidung,
belegen und Beweisführung machen. Da ist jetzt in diesem speziellen Fall irgendwie ein Schaden für den Wettbewerb oder für Konsumentinnen entstanden ähm und deswegen
Diese Strafe, sondern lass uns doch einfach eine Liste machen an
Verhalten von großen Unternehmen, die wir schon wissen, dass die schädlich sind für den Wettbewerb und das einfach von vornherein verbieten. Ähm und äh das ist natürlich ein riskanter Ansatz, denn man.
Dreht damit die Beweislaste im Prinzip um, ähm aber die Kommission hat das geschafft, dass so ein,
eng im Anwendungsbereich zu formulieren dass das am Schluss doch auch in Ordnung geht vor allem aus unserer Sicht natürlich denn hier geht's tatsächlich um die Limitierung der Marktmacht.
Die größten von diesen äh Tech-Unternehmen äh aktuell haben.
Digital Markets Akt arbeitet da mit einer Definition von Gate Keeper. Ähm der ist also nur anwendbar auf Unternehmen, die so als sogenannte Gate-Keeper auftreten, also als Unternehmen, die zwischen.
Ähm Nutzerinnen und Nutzern auf der einen und Anbietern von Dienstleistungen oder anderen Nutzern sitzen. Ähm
und äh das ist zum Beispiel ein klassischer Geldkeeper wäre zum Beispiel Amazon, die stellen den Marktplatz bereit
sind und äh ja halten quasi das sind Türsteher für den Zugang von unseren Nutzern zu ähm zu den
Verkäufern, aber auch von Verkäuferinnen und Verkäufern führt zu den Nutzern und das ist ein die Situation, die hier der der DMA versucht ähm ja zu lösen, sage.
Aber es gibt eine Reihe mehr an Geldkeepern noch, also ein Anbieter von Apple, Apple Appstole, klassischer Geldgeber, ähm die sind die einzigen, über die man an Apps für iPhones drankommt. Ähm und deswegen fällt Apple damit
unter den Anwendungsbereich des DMA.
Und dann gibt's eben im DMA eine ganz lange Liste an, verboten und Verpflichtungen, äh die einfach.
Grundsätzlich gelten für solche Geldgeber. Wenn man einmal als Geldkeeper definiert ist von der Kommission
dann muss man sich an diese Regeln halten und das halten wir für einen sehr sehr guten Ansatz. Der ist auch grundsätzlich, soweit ich das überblicken kann, in Brüssel von niemandem ernsthaft in Frage gestellt, selbst von den
Unternehmen wird dieser Ansatz nicht grundsätzlich in Frage gestellt.
Okay und was soll jetzt da konkret ähm geregelt werden? Also wir haben ja hier auch schon mal über äh also diese Messenger, Interoperabilität äh gesprochen. Das fällt ja da auch mit rein, ne.
Genau, also eine der Verpflichtungen, die im ursprünglichen Vorschlag der Kommission nicht drin standen, aber die das Parlament reingeschrieben hat, ist eben für äh Anbieter von MessagingApps äh und sozialen Netzwerken eine interoporabilität
mit anderen Messaging-Apps und sozialen Netzwerken zu ermöglichen. Wenn diese anderen in Klammern nicht Geldkeeper
Messenger und soziale Netzwerke das denn wünschen. Ähm das heißt, das ist keine Verpflichtung zum Miteinander zusammenarbeiten, aber die
der Anbieter muss äh eine entsprechende Schnittstelle API
open standard äh äh was auch immer dafür notwendig ist, dann äh zur Verfügung stellen, um so eine Intermobilität von sogenannten äh äh
Code Service ist ähm äh möglich zu machen. Die Kommission wird hinterher die Macht haben äh oder dass die die Möglichkeit haben, das genauer zu definieren. Was sind denn eigentlich Core-Services, was gehört denn zum eigentlich zum zum hm ja zum Kern eines, eines sozialen Netzwerkes, was da interoporabel sein muss ähm und äh und
wenn das denn so im finalen Gesetz drinbleibt, dann glaube ich, wäre das schon eine erhebliche äh Veränderung von Nutzernutzer, sondern auch in aus unserer Sicht eine erhebliche Verbesserung.
Also Moment jetzt, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe, um da mal die die,
Chor-Services beim Namenszünde. Das wäre also so was wie WhatsApp, ne? Also WhatsApp ist verpflichtend wäre dann verpflichtet eine ein irgendwie definierten Standard anzubieten, der
kleineren Konkurrentinnen ermöglicht mit WhatsApp zu interagieren, wenn sie möchten.
Aber während WhatsApp verpflichtet ist das anzubieten, sind es die Kleinen nicht. Das kann man ja relativ einfach über die Verbreitung Userin, Zahl oder Sonstiges machen.
Genau und da gibt's auch eine eine eine Schwelle, die da festgelegt ist im Gesetz.
So, konkrete Ziele wären dann, was weiß ich, so was wie iMessage, WhatsApp wahrscheinlich, ne? Das wären jetzt so.
Bei den Messengern wären das die. Beim sozialen Netzwerk ist es vor allem äh natürlich Facebook. Ähm Twitter könnte auch drunter fallen. Ähm wobei ich da nicht ganz sicher bin, ob Twitter drunter fällt.
Und jetzt also wir haben das Thema ja hier vor einiger Zeit in der Sendung schon mal diskutiert, dass wir halt also das müsste ja ihr also.
Mal vorsichtig gesagt. Also die die Messenger versuchen ja durchaus sich voneinander.
Abzugrenzen durch äh was weiß ich Innovation, ja? Also,
sei es wie sie eine Gruppe definieren, wie groß sie sein kann, ähm ob man da eine ein
Kanal machen kann, in dem nur man selber Verschwörungstheorien posten darf oder äh in dem andere äh
Holocaustleugner mit äh posten dürfen und und und was nicht alles, ja. Ähm.
Jetzt wäre halt die Frage, also es müsste ja im Prinzip ein ein Minimalstandard definiert sein und der die die Falle, die wir immer dabei gesehen haben.
Ist über den also da wird ja dann der Vertrauensbereich.
Einen Messengers verlassen. Ja und jetzt könnt ihr ja zum Beispiel äh jemand sagen, pass ob,
Ich benutze Signal, gerade damit mich niemand von WhatsApp erreichen kann und ich möchte auch nicht, dass das passiert und ich will auch nicht diese komischen Sticker von denen haben.
Ja? Ähm was also was äh.
Ist dann dieser Minimalstandard und wie kann der passieren ohne dass er letztendlich eine eine Schwächung der Sicherheit, des des Gesamtsystemes?
Darstellt, ja? Einfachstes Beispiel.
Ich benutze Telegram, weil die Innenministerin nicht die Telefonnummer von.
Äh Telegram hat, ja? Kann ja durchaus sein, dass Leute das tun. Ja, das heißt, für die wäre es jetzt potenziell gar nicht so positiv, wenn äh Telegram und WhatsApp eine
Ausführliche Form der Zusammenarbeit hätten. Und was ich auch sehr spannend finde, wenn man nur die großen dazu ähm verdonnert, das zu tun, kann es ja.
Also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass vielleicht wirklich Privatsphäre und Sicherheit interessierte Messenger sagen äh danke kein Interesse.
Kann absolut passieren, ist auch vollkommen legitim. Also niemand wird durch so eine Regelung dazu gezwungen, mit,
mit einem Geldkeeperanbieter äh irgendwie zusammenzuarbeiten äh ja oder oder ja oder selbst überhaupt äh so eine so eine Intoperabilität dann zu nutzen. Das steht den kleinen Anbietern absolut frei.
Das zu tun oder das nicht zu tun.
Bisschen den, ob die das überhaupt wollen. Also ich meine, wie steht denn zum Beispiel Frima äh dazu?
So der klassische kleine Anbieter, der sich vor allem durch äh besonders pfiffige und super anonyme Verschlüsselung
den anderen differenziert und von daher ja eigentlich überhaupt gar keine gar kein Interesse daran hat, dass ihr Schema in irgendeiner Form die eigene Plattform verlässt.
Also wir haben mit den Leuten von von Threema nicht gesprochen. Wir wissen von Signal, dass es da kein Interesse gibt. Ich glaube, das ist öffentlich bekannt, dass das Moxi kein großer Fan von irgendeiner Form von Dezentralisierung oder Intermobilität ist. Ähm.
Wir
Wir wissen aber auch, dass es Messenger gibt, wie wie wie Matics oder Element, äh die ein großes Interesse daran haben. Äh wir denken auch an äh on all in one Apps, äh die versuchen mehrere Messenger in einer App zu bündeln. Auch die hätten einen
großen Vorteil von so einer
regelung, weil dadurch eben eine größere Stabilität für die ähm käme und äh die Technologie, die sie nutzen müssten, um äh diese All-in-One-Messenger zu bauen.
Würde sich stark vereinfachen und ich glaube das ist auch eine der wichtigsten Punkte die die man im im Hinterkopf behalten muss. Es ist
gibt viele verschiedene Art und Weisen das zu nutzen man kann quasi direktes Messaging machen zwischen zwei Netzwerken, man könnte aber auch ähm einfach sagen hey du kannst innerhalb meines Messengers verschiedene Netzwerke anschreiben.
Ähm und je nachdem, wo, in welchem anderen, in welcher anderen App die Person sitzt, mit der du da gerade sprichst, den Sicherheitsstandard hast du dann eben. Ähm
das lässt sich ja auch, das kann man durchaus ja auch entsprechend visuell
darstellen genauso wie Signal zumindest auf Android-Telefonen ja durchaus eben ermöglicht verschlüsselte Signalnachrichten auszutauschen, aber auch völlig unverschlüsselte SMS, alles in einer App. Ähm das
SMS-Funktion verhindert aber nicht, dass der Rest von Signal sicher bleibt.
Weder so eine Android-Welt sein. Also mein Signal verschickt sicherlich keine unverschlüsselten Nachrichten.
Ja, das ist bei, das ist bei Apple ein bisschen anders, weil äh ich glaube, äh Apple ist nicht erlaubt, dass andere Apps als die ureigene Apple äh SMS-App irgendwelche SMS verschickt. Ähm Android ist da ein bisschen offener und erlaubt äh Erbs von Drittanbietern SMS zu verschicken und
Hat gesagt, klar, bauen wir mit ein. Ähm haben sie gemacht und ist, soweit ich das überblicken kann, jetzt bisher auch kein großes Problem, was irgendwie die Sicherheit
der Nutzerinnenutzer unterläuft. Ähm also ich glaube, da gibt es schon, gibt es gute Lösungen dafür, ähm die wirkliche,
kompliziertere Frage kommt eigentlich im Bereich soziale Netzwerke zustande
nicht so sehr bei den Messageern. Das ich glaube für die Messenger das ist relativ straightforward. Ähm das sind.
Ja, du hast kurz die Maß äh zu die die Erwartungen von von Menschen angesprochen, über wie äh ja, wie irgendwie
in dem geschlossenen Bereich von einem geschlossenen Messenger dann plötzlich da irgendwie dann raus sind aus dem geschlossenen Bereich. Ähm ich glaube, das sind Erwartungen, die jetzt einfach auch entstanden sind durch die Art und Weise, wie zentralisierter Messenger seit einiger Zeit funktionieren.
Aber Leute haben sich auch an andere Modelle gewöhnt. Bei der E-Mail hat sich auch niemand gefragt, oh wo landet denn meine E-Mail jetzt, wenn jemand anders irgendwie Gmail benutzt und ich nicht. Das ist halt einfach so. Wenn ich jemandem schreibe, der eine E-Mail-Adresse hat, dann
dann dann muss ich davon ausgehen, dass meine Daten von Google gelesen werden, da kann ich selbst noch so Privatsphäre ähm affin sein
da kann ich nichts dran ändern. Bei E-Mail ist es sogar noch schlimmer, denn bei E-Mail können sich die Leute ja hinter einer Custom-Doman verstecken. Das heißt, ich weiß gar nicht, was die für einen Anbieter verwenden und trotzdem schreiben alle Leute E-Mails.
Also das ist für mich das das beste Beispiel sorry also auf das eBay-Beispiel habe ich gewartet. Das ist wirklich das beste Beispiel ähm wie trotz absoluter Interoperabilität.
Am Ende doch alle bei Gmails sind, ne und auch wie.
Ja, ne, also schau dir doch an, wer da also wer betreibt denn heute noch seine eigenen E-Mail-Server?
Gut, es gibt ja noch andere Möglichkeiten als entweder Gmail oder seinen eigenen E-Mail-Server.
Ja, es gibt dann noch Microsoft und iCloud und äh damit hast du wahrscheinlich aber auch schon 99 Prozent abgedeckt.
Du kannst hier also Mailbox dot org und posteo ähm den gibt's ja noch Trutanota, gibt ja noch ein Deutschen. Äh.
Ja klar, es gibt ein paar dedizierte Mailbox äh Anbieter, E-Mail-Anbieter, aber das hält sich in Grenzen, ne.
Die können jetzt, also die schaffen es jetzt nicht, dank der Operabilität entscheidende Marktanteile äh Google wegzunehmen.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir haben wir mit E-Mail,
perfekte Beispiel dafür, dass halt so ein filderiertes System, das ist ja Moxis Argument, ne? Der der also kann man ja zur zur Vollständigkeit hier nochmal auch äh kurz wiedergeben. Der hat sinngemäß.
Wenn du einen filderrierten Standard hast, dann ist der einmal spezifizierter, er wird sich aufgrund der ähm Rückwärtskopatibilität und der unterschiedlichen Interessen,
mehr sinnvoll weiterentwickeln, ne? Also und als Beispiel führt er heran, E-Mail, ja, gibt es seit über einem Vierteljahrhundert Verschlüsselung. Dafür gibt's seit einem Vierteljahrhundert, hat sich aber einfach nie durchgesetzt, weil
alle quasi na ja den Standard
unten halten auf dem kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner, statt ihnen gemeinsam äh hochzuziehen und.
Gleichzeitig hat's hast du nicht einer Zentralisierungstendenz vorbeugen können. So das das ist jetzt so.
Das Argument am lebenden Objekt E-Mail.
Und das und das und das ist ja auch, wenn ich das auch noch mal äh anfügen kann, weil wir hatten das jetzt hier vor ein paar Sendungen auch schon mal ausführlich äh diskutiert. So, mehr aus so einer technischen Perspektive, ne. Das ist einfach hier an der Stelle auch sehr schwierig sein wird,
für die EU
Ganze auch korrekt zu spezifizieren. Ja, also entweder man belässt es bei bei superschwammigen müsste man mal und hätte müsste eigentlich so sein äh,
kann man aber jetzt nicht genau sagen, weil es jedes Mal anders Formulierungen
oder man geht halt irgendwie den schweren Weg und äh geht wirklich in die Details definiert.
Kolle und und und begibt sich quasi in dieses äh schwere Gebiet von äh Internet
Protokollspezifikation A-Piece, das ist doch einfach für so einen politischen Körper nicht zu leisten und wenn man sagt, na ja, dann müsst ihr euch halt irgendwie einig werden, na dann wird es halt wirklich dieser aller-, allerkleinste gemeinsame Nenner sein, der auf der einen Seite nicht viel,
übersetzen kann, ja, weil die einfach alle unterschiedliche Adressierungssysteme haben, alle
unterschiedliche Verschlüsselungssysteme haben, die sie ja dann auch nicht aufweichen wollen. Also gerade vorhin hatten wir noch dieses Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, muss irgendwie beibehalten werden.
Wie will man das irgendwie im Messenger übergreifend sicherstellen.
Ohne nicht irgendwie komplett äh entweder zu vereinheitlichen, was keiner will, weil alle haben ein anderes Modell und wollen ja genau das dann auch nicht nicht aufbrechen oder eben eine entsprechende Entschlüsselungs
Grenze zu schaffen, weil sonst Nachrichten ja überhaupt nicht zu übertragen werden. Also wo man da auch ansetzt, wir sehen da ganz viele
konkrete technische Probleme, die kaum zu überwinden sind.
OK also ich sag mal zwei Sachen. Nochmal vielleicht zu der Verschlüsselungsfrage weil das auch etwas ist was im in der im politischen Diskurs immer mal wieder aufgekommen ist. Es spricht doch nichts dagegen, dass eine App
wie zum Beispiel Signat oder jeder andere, die da vielleicht Interesse zeigen könnte. Ähm es den Nutzerinnen und Nutzern erlaubt
zwei verschiedene Netzwerke anzusprechen und das entsprechend zu markieren zu sagen jetzt sprichst du mit jemandem auf WhatsApp.
Gibt's halt die WhatsApp-Verschlüsselung, die verschlüsselt die Inhalte, aber verschlüsselt leider nicht die Metadaten. Ähm sei dir dessen bewusst und los geht's,
Signalperson, da ist das ganz anders. Dass in eine App zusammen zu integrieren, das spricht auch überhaupt nichts dagegen. Dazu muss man sich nicht auf einen
minimal Standard von von WhatsApp irgendwie einigen. Und vielleicht noch zwei Punkte zu dem Beispiel von E-Mail, weil das in der Tat natürlich
sage ich mal ein leichtes Ziel der Kritik ist, weil E-Mail tatsächlich ähm einfach ja viel weil bei E-Mail sind viele Dinge schiefgelaufen sicherlich in der langen Geschichte ähm und es ist eigentlich überraschend, dass die E-Mail überhaupt noch.
Noch da ist nach so langer Zeit. Ähm es gibt sicherlich sehr sehr viele Gründe, warum äh sich die äh die E-Mail-Landschaft immer stärker zentralisiert und ja vielleicht tatsächlich viele Leute
zu zu Gina wechseln ähm.
Und äh und es ist sicherlich ja und als als Ergebnis würde ich eher sagen, es ist so, dass sich die E-Mail-Landschaft zentralisiert, trotz der Interpabilität, aber nicht wegen der Interrobilität. Ich glaube.
Ja
Zu glauben, dass die Interrobilität als alleiniges Allheilmittel alle Probleme
ähm äh löst. Bei E-Mail ist es ganz genau so ein ein Wettbewerbsproblem, äh wie das auch äh in anderen Bereichen der Fall ist. Auch das soll der DMA ja würde der DMA ja idealerweise auch mit anderen Maßnahmen,
angehen. Äh ob das funktioniert, muss ich zeigen. Ähm aber wenn man eben ein Unternehmen hat, welches einen bestimmten E-Mail-Dienst auf.
Weiß nicht den genauen Marktanteil von Android-Telefonen auf, dass ich 80 Prozent aller Telefone schon vorinstalliert, ist doch selbstverständlich, dass die Leute dann
automatisch bei bei Google sind. Wenn ein solches Unternehmen dann auch noch so viele Milliarden Euro aufm Konto hat, dass die kostenlos unbegrenzten Speicherblatt zur Verfügung gestellt. Natürlich ist das ein riesiger Wettbewerbsvorteil.
Die da noch eine geniale E-Mail-Suche einbauen können, weil sie nebenher noch Zugriff auf aller möglichen persönlichen Daten haben aus den 100 anderen Diensten, die die noch kostenlos anbieten. Natürlich.
Ein Vorteil am Schluss. Und die genau das sind die Punkte, die der DMA versucht zu lösen mit den verschiedenen Verboten, ähm aber dass quasi alles jetzt dann der Interporbilität auf die Schulter zu nehmen und zu sagen, oh guck mal, das kann die jetzt aber alleine nicht lösen, deswegen
setzen wir's gar nicht erst in Kraft. Ähm das wäre mir zu kurz gesprungen am.
Eine absolut.
Sicherlich eine Maßnahme sein von vielen, ähm die in der Kombination hoffentlich dann dazu führt, dass die
Nutzer eine größere Möglichkeit haben äh oder leichter die Möglichkeit dann wahrnehmen können, auch zu kleineren Anbietern zu wechseln, ähm ohne den Kontakt mit den Leuten auf den großen Plattformen zu verlieren.
Und äh da hast du natürlich also damit hast du ja vollkommen recht und damit das ist dass das ein dass das ein Heeresziel ist auch völlig. Ähm.
Auch also bei Tim und mir schlagen da ja natürlich auch zwei Herzen in der Brust. Ähm wir wir,
folgen ja dem Ziel, ne, also das politische Ziel ist ja äh erstrebenswert. Wir haben Zweifel, dass es sich auf diesem Wege noch erreichen lässt. Gleichzeitig äh gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es äh,
unsere Interessen wenig Schaden nehmen, wenn man's jetzt äh wenn man das jetzt erzwingt, ja ähm.
Ich würde fast allerdings fürchten, weil du jetzt gerade also meine kleine äh Linus im versteckten Kämmerlein-These ist, das,
der DMA dann mit dieser Interoperabilitätsverpflichtung ähnlich zu spät kommt,
wie die DSGVO, ja, wo wo wir auch eine Situation hatten, die wenn die DSGVO zehn Jahre vorher da gewesen wäre, da hätte sie Teile dieser Marktentwicklungen.
Potenziell eindämmen oder verhindern können. Als sie dann kam, könnte man jetzt könnten böse Zungen behaupten.
Dass dann nämlich genau die Situation war oder die Situation äh zu beobachten war, dass Facebook und Google und äh die.
Sogenannten Hyperscailer längst äh die Macht hatten, um letztendlich ihren Login dazu zu nutzen, dass ihre Nutzerinnen eh allem.
Informiert zustimmen. Ja und äh der Rest der Zeit, wie du gerade auch schon sagtest,
nochmal drei, vier Jahre prozessiert wird ähm bis die Realität äh längst das Recht und das Ziel des Gesetzes überholt hat. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen
ja die Sorge bei dieser Interpauilitätsforderung, aber ich will uns da jetzt auch nicht dran aufhalten. Ich glaube, ich habe die also diese Debatte soll jetzt nicht den Eindruck vermitteln, dass wir dir widersprechen, sondern äh wir wollten natürlich auch so ein bisschen darauf.
Aufmerksam machen, wie ja, wie schwierig das ist, ne. Also das Problem ist noch lange nicht gelöst und das ist ein Ansatz, der.
Eventuell einen Beitrag dazu leisten kann.
Aber Widerspruch ist auch immer gut und äh wo ich völlig zustimme ist ähm Interoper Interoperable Systeme zu bauen ist immer schwieriger als zentralisierte geschlossene Systeme. Das absolut ja.
Definitiv.
Ein ähnlicher Bereich ähm ist ja die Diskussion um die Öffnung von diesen App Stores auf äh Drittanbieter. Die wird ja im Rahmen des DMA auch geführt, oder?
Genau, das ist ein Vorschlag, der schon äh äh der schon von der Kommission eingefügt wurde in den Originalen, den ursprünglichen Vorschlag des DMA und der jetzt auch, soweit ich das überblicke, in sowohl der Parlamentsposition weiter mit drin ist, als auch in der Ratsposition.
Die haben also tatsächlich gesehen, okay wenn man eben hier sogenannte Geldkeeper halt dann da hat, die die den
Appstore äh kontrollieren und das Betriebssystem kontrollieren und das Gerät kontrollieren, dann ist das eben sehr sehr viel Macht in der Hand äh eines Unternehmens und äh jetzt die Streits und auch die Rechtsstreits, die ja gegen Apple geführt werden und wurden.
Was jetzt zum Beispiel die Apple Tags angeht, also den Betrag, den App Entwickler zahlen müssen, um im App Store ihre Apps verkaufen zu können.
Als anteilig vom Verkaufserlös dass das natürlich etwas ist was was große Macht im Unternehmen gibt äh ich glaube das da steht außer Frage. Frage wie man damit umgeht. Die Kommission hat gesagt hey
Eigentlich müssten doch auch iPhone Nutzer das Recht haben, wenn sie das wünschen. So wie es bei Android ja auch schon der Fall ist, eben ein
einen Appstore von einem Drittanbieter zu installieren und sich die Apps von woanders zu holen. Äh
Apple hat das mit ja verteidigt sich dann noch mit zehn und Clown und und äh mit mit größter Macht und will das um um jeden Preis verhindern
weil das für die natürlich bedeutet ein großer
Teil ihres ihrer Einnahmen äh bricht da weg aus aus den aus dem Erbgeschäft ähm und ihr Hauptargument äh was Apple vorbringt ist vor allem.
Der Privatsphäre und Datensicherheit. Ähm also so das Horrorszenario, was Apple den Politikerinnen und Politikern gegenüber an die Wand malt, ist
Wenn ihr das zulasst im Gesetz
werden iPhone Benutzerinnen und Benutzer in Zukunft ähm von Malwehr überschwemmt und werden gehackt die ganze Zeit und verlieren ihre Daten und so weiter. Also
ganz schlimme Horrorszenarien, die da im im Lobbying an an die Wand gemalt werden.
Ja. Kann ich sogar teilweise nachvollziehen, äh muss ich sagen, weil ich meine, wenn ich das jetzt mal so aus Nutzerperspektive äh sehe, ne, sehe ich jetzt gar nicht mal unbedingt so äh auf den ersten Blick irgendeinen Vorteil dadrin.
Das ähm äh aufgeteilt wird. Also warum will ich verschiedene.
Marktanbieter haben für meine Apps. Das macht mir die Sache ja erstmal komplexer, genauer genommen könnt ihr ja im Prinzip jede App auch genau an dieser einen Stelle zu finden sein und warum sollte ich überhaupt erst die an zehn verschiedenen.
Stellen finden wollen und gerade das Beispiel und und und dritte App Stores ist ja auch teilweise ein totales äh,
Drama, was was sich da security-mäßig findet, weil wenn du dann halt mal wirklich in dieser anderen Stores reinschaust, da ist dann halt einfach alles voll mit äh und äh.
Software und das äh kann's ja nun auch nicht sein, ne. Also das äh das macht man jetzt hier auf und ich finde dieses Argument ein bisschen.
Merkwürdig, dass es jetzt hier sozusagen primär ums Geld geht. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch äh.
Natürlich geht's primär ums Geld, Tim, sorry. Also Apple nimmt nimmt dreißig Prozent,
von den Entwicklern, ja, für diese äh für die Dienstleistung der Bereitstellung einer signierten App in einem zentralen App Store, ja und dem entgegenzutreten ist ja schon also.
Ich ich stimme dir zu, dass ich persönlich es nicht für erstrebenswert halte, dass ich mehrere App Stores brauche, um irgendwie einen.
App Konvolut auf meinem iPhone zu haben und das für Android-Charts das jetzt zu öffnen, ja? Aber ich ähm fände es auch verhältnismäßig angenehm, wenn die Entwickler der Software.
Ähm nicht unbedingt äh so dermaßen an den Ketten von Apple hängen würden. Ja, inklusive
ja Situation, dass ihre Software dann nicht aufs iPhone darf, weil irgendwo meine Brust im Bild war oder was auch immer. Da.
Okay, aber jetzt reden wir über zwei Sachen, ne. Das eine ist.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Doch doch. Also erstmal stimmt das mit den dreißig Prozent äh sowieso nicht mehr, ja? Es sind im Wesentlichen für die Allermeisten sind's fünfzehn äh Prozent. Also für die allermeisten äh grade für die kleinen Entwickler hat es dieser Betrag ja äh gefallen.
Und äh das betrifft sozusagen vor allem die die Großen, äh die dort äh agieren, also ab einem bestimmten Umsatz äh musst du halt dann irgendwie auf diese dreißig Prozent gehen.
Und ähm jetzt habe ich gerade den Train of South äh ein wenig äh verloren. Man muss ja auch sehen.
A, was was war ja vorher die Situation, ne? Vorher ist ja dieses ganze Payment über äh entsprechende Payment Provider gelaufen und äh da war's halt halt auch nicht unbedingt so, dass sie jetzt irgendwie unter dreißig Prozent gelandet bist.
Schwierig wird es halt nur bei diesen ganzen.
Kann man natürlich drüber äh diskutieren, ob das sozusagen jetzt ein angemessener Betrag ist oder nicht, ne. Aber die die Diskussion, ich will jetzt, ich weiß, bin ich schon wieder äh Apple Apologet und so weiter, aber ich äh habe mich einfach mit dieser
Frage auch sehr aus der Perspektive von Entwicklern äh,
beschäftigt, ja, die da nicht äh unbedingt so drauf sind, dass sie sagen so, oh ja, ich brauche jetzt unbedingt einen anderen Markt, damit die mir mein Geld wegnehmen, weil so viel werde ich mir da nicht sparen. Aber dann muss ich irgendwie auch noch mit mehreren Anbietern und äh,
meine Kunden mit verschiedenen Interfaces arbeiten und so weiter und am Ende wird das alles nur sehr viel mehr Arbeit sein, ja und was es dann irgendwie mit den Security-Standards
soll die dann äh entforsten. Was ist wenn die dann alle unterschiedliche Security-Standards haben? Also das äh äh aus Entwicklerperspektiv
sehe ich das jetzt mal gar nicht so als Gesetz an, dass das jetzt äh unbedingt so gewünscht ist. Ja, jetzt kann man natürlich über die
Anteile und den Geld äh Betrag und so weiter äh diskutieren, aber was ja im Prinzip dahinter steht, ist eigentlich
Was heißt ohne Chip dieser Plattform? Und äh gilt das jetzt was für Apple? Gilt, gilt das dann auch für meine Nintendo-Spielekonsole?
Also wo fängt das denn jetzt an? Ja, muss dann irgendwie auch VW in seinem Auto, wenn ich da Apps runterlade, auch.
Party-Stores anbieten.
Dann können wir endlich Tesla full autonomis driving aufm.
Tesla ist jetzt auch dabei, demnächst im App Store äh rauszubringen
Diesen da haben sie jetzt gerade angekündigt. So also wo fängt das an? Wo hört das auf? Ja wenn ich jetzt ein Gerät mache und ich öffne eine Schnittstelle um Dritten überhaupt zu ermöglichen, zu meinen Bedingungen überhaupt
daran teilzunehmen, ja? Es ist ja sozusagen es gibt ja auch keine App Storepflicht in dem Sinne. Äh es ist ja nicht.
Nicht so, dass ich gezwungen bin, unbedingt immer alle auf mein Produkt drauf zu lassen. Ich kann ein Auto anbieten und kann sagen, ja alle
Apps, die's da gibt, mache ich. Ich habe natürlich ein Interesse dadran. Jetzt vielleicht äh zur Party Apps da äh reinzulassen, aber bin ich dann auch automatisch gezwungen,
Dritte, die damit erstmal überhaupt nix zu tun haben, die sozusagen an diesem ganzen Plattform, Development ja überhaupt nicht beteiligt sind, eine Verdienstmöglichkeit zu geben.
Damit dann das Geld, was ich darüber verdiene, mit dem ich ja quasi auch den Aufwand,
refinanziere, den ich habe, um das überhaupt erst zu ermöglichen. Ähm ja, das mir dann der auch wieder weggenommen wird. Also ich sehe diese Legitimation und diese Notwendigkeit nicht unbedingt.
Das ist ja der das ist ja der ganze Sinn und Zweck des Digitalen.
Digital Marketsact. Ähm dass das eben hier nicht um alle möglichen Unternehmen geht, sondern um Geldkeeper-Unternehmen. Das heißt, es geht um sehr, sehr große, sehr, sehr mächtige Unternehmen, die in einer Position sind, dass andere
zum Beispiel Wettbewerber oder auch Nutzerinnen und Nutzer, um diese nicht mehr herumkommen.
Weil die so groß und einflussreich sind. Nur um solche geht's, nicht um andere. Wenn also Tesla oder VW mit seinem mit ihrem App-Store so in so eine Position geraten, dann würden solche Verpflichtungen natürlich auch für diejenigen gelten jetzt.
Aber dazu sagen, ich will natürlich auch schöne spannende Debatte um die wie viel Prozent jetzt Erb der bezahlen, nicht nicht abwürgen, aber von Seite kümmern wir uns, wir sind ja wir sind ja keine Erbentwicklerrechteorganisation, sondern wir sind Menschenrechtsorganisation, das heißt, was uns in erster Linie interessiert, ist nicht wer, wie viel wofür bezahlt.
Was uns in erster Linie interessiert ist, wer hat denn eigentlich die Kontrolle darüber? Welche Software auf unseren Geräten ausgeführt werden kann.
Traditionellerweise Computer, Laptops und so weiter, sind wir eigentlich gewöhnt, dass wenn ich einen Laptop kaufe, stelle ich den bei mir zu Hause hin, dann kann ich da drauf kann ich damit machen, was ich will. Ich kann dadrauf ausführen, was ich will. Ich lade mir die Software runter, die ich gerne
installieren will und die benutze ich dann. Das ist mein Gerät.
Das hat sich eben im in diesem mobilen Systemen geändert und das war ganz klar nicht eine
Sicherheitsentscheidung zu Beginn, sondern es war ganz klar eine kommerzielle Entscheidung zu sagen, wenn wir die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer dazu bringen können, nur diejenigen Apps zu benutzen,
Ihnen verkaufen in diesem Fall, weil's natürlich kommerziell Transition ist. Dann haben wir die Kontrolle darüber und können die Nutzerinnenutzer.
Eben auch an uns binden. Der Grund, warum Apple und Google eben so dominant sind aufm mobilen Markt oder einer der Gründe, ist nun mal auch, weil die diese App Stores haben, wo die ganzen Apps drin sind und wenn man diese Apps will,
muss man eben so ein Telefon kaufen, denn die kriegt man nirgendswo anders. Ähm und äh und ich glaube, dass das das das da so ein bisschen der Hase begraben liegt, dass wenn wir diese Freiheit
für Menschen wiedergewinnen wollen, selbst zu entscheiden, welche Software sie auf ihren Geräten laufen lassen wollen, welchen Softwarequellen sie vertrauen, ähm,
brauchen wir eben diese Freiheit auch zu installieren oder andere Quellen zu installieren für die Software.
Und jetzt deine Appe Liebe in in allen Ehren, aber da das basiert vor allem auch diese Sicherheitsargumente, basieren vor allem eben auch auf der Annahme
oder nicht, dass Apple heute und in aller Zukunft für die Sicherheit deines Gerätes sorgen wird.
Und da sorry, wenn ich das so sagen muss, steckst du einfach auch ein hohes Maß an Vertrauen in dieses Unternehmen, würde ich so nicht machen wollen. Da vertraue ich mir lieber selbst. Ähm und noch mal, das heißt ja nicht, dass man ein Gerät nicht auch
sicher
gestalten kann, dass man sagen kann, man kann eine Warnung für Nutzerinnen Nutzer machen, bevor die das installieren. Ähm es gibt aber es geht aber natürlich auch um die Möglichkeit für Drittanbieter oder Hersteller von Smartphones, dass die im
Herstellungsprozess schon entscheiden können, welche ähm äh Softwarequellen möchte ich denn meinen Kundinnen und Kunden anbieten.
Nicht spricht doch dagegen, dass Samsung von seinem neuesten Galaxy-Telefon drei Versionen verkauft, eins mit Google Play Store, eins mit Amazon, was weiß ich Store und eins mit F-Droid drauf. Ähm fände ich persönlich eine coole.
Verkaufen sie drei.
Kaufen sie verschiedene Geräte und dann und dann können sich die Leute nämlich aussuchen.
Ja gut, aber dann haben ja aber äh also mit der bei der Sicherheit, also ehrlich gesagt, natürlich muss ich äh äh Apple damit vertrauen, ich vertraue denen ja schon deshalb, weil ich über die Plattform an sich auswähle.
Das ist ja sozusagen schon der Inbegriff des Vertrauens. Und wer sollte denn sonst ein Interesse daran haben, die Sicherheit auf dieser Plattform herzustellen als Apple?
Einzel-Partymarkt hat nur ein Interesse dadran, maximal viel zu verkaufen. An der Sicherheit der Plattform äh für die äh die Bilder
Aufwand treiben müssen noch in irgendeiner Form einer Entwicklung beteiligt sind, noch dafür haften. Haben die überhaupt gar kein Interesse. Von daher äh dreht sich das Argument an der Stelle äh aus meiner Perspektive eher um,
Also äh das ist ja genau das Problem. Auf einmal habe ich da einen Handelspartner, der sozusagen kein Interesse hat und wenn die eigentliche Frage, die du da ja stellst, ist ja nicht wer verkauft wer lädt mir jetzt die App runter?
Sondern unter welchen Bedingungen
äh was sind sozusagen die Regeln für die Zulassung von so einer Software? Das ist doch eigentlich das.
Eine Zulassung von solcher Software.
Na ja warum's die gibt, ist doch klar,
halt auch noch andere Aspekte gibt als nur äh darf auf die Plattform drauf oder nicht wegen Geld und Konkurrenz, sondern weil's natürlich auch noch den Aspekt gibt, Privacy und natürlich den Aspekt Sicherheit gibt und das ist ja etwas, was diese App Stores auch machen.
Den will ich ja auch sichergestellt wissen und äh sehe das halt nicht zwangsläufig so, dass mir ein Markt.
Der eigentlich daran gar kein Interesse hat.
Mir auf einmal etwas zugänglich macht, was nicht diesen selben Anforderungen entspricht. Es wäre vielleicht sinnvoller, ja doch hier einfach klare Regeln für die Zulassung von äh Software anzugehen, die generell für alle Märkt.
Finde ich interessant, würde ich aber insofern widersprechen als anstatt quasi diesem einen Monopolmarkt jetzt äh staatliche Regeln aufzuersetzen, was der alles aufnehmen muss und was nicht, würde ich lieber sagen, lass uns verschiedene Märkte machen und jeder sucht sich den aus denen er vertraut.
Apple kann ja weiterhin seine Geräte mit seinem Markt vorinstalliert ausliefern aber es sollte nicht anderen Menschen äh vorschreiben welche App sie auf ihren Telefonen installieren können und welche nicht und insofern finde ich das bezeichnend, dass ähm in dieser Debatte häufig eben die Rede ist von
Plattformen, oh die können doch selbst entscheiden, was auf ihrer Plattform. Nee, das ist nicht deren Plattform. Das ist mein Gerät. Das habe ich für teures Geld gekauft. Damit mache ich, was ich will.
Das entscheidet nicht Apple, das ist nicht mehr deren Plattform. Sobald es den Ladentisch auf zu mir übergeht, dann ist das nicht mehr deren Plattform. Ähm aber das ist natürlich ein Narrativ, was Apple überhaupt nicht gefällt.
Sondern sondern die argumentieren in der Tat immer oder.
Formulieren das immer so, als ob es sich äh bis auf alle Ewigkeit jedes iPhone immer in Wirklichkeit deren Gerät oder deren Plattform ist. Nur ich glaube, dass hier eine Chance besteht für
für das Gesetz einzugreifen, ähm dass das natürlich dazu führen könnte, dass die ein oder andere Person sich aus Versehen mal was installiert, was sie dann hinterher bereut, ist völlig selbstverständlich. Das ist bei PCs heute auch der Fall. Ähm und äh insofern ist natürlich äh.
Ja, aber wenn es nicht mehr hm ich weiß, ich weiß, wie du darüber denkst, aber man muss natürlich auch bedenken, in dem Moment, wo man die also wenn man diesen Gedanken fortführt und sagt, okay, jetzt ist es mein Gerät und nicht mehr deine Plattform. Ja?
Dann dann wo ist denn dann die Haftung? Also das.
Ist ja auch ein Haftungs äh Ding, ne? Und Haftung heißt ja nicht nur zum Zeitpunkt des Verkaufs, sondern eben auch über über die komplette Lifetime Updates fordern wir ja auch irgendwie, dass Plattformen sicher gehalten werden.
Sie dann aber auf einmal gar keine Plattformen mehr sind. Ja wieso hast du gekauft? Ist jetzt irgendwie dein Problem, dann würde sie ja sozusagen auch das nicht mehr entgehen. Also ich sage nur, ist schwierig.
Den Verhaftungsfall möchte ich noch sehen, indem ein eine iPhone-Besitzerin bei Apple
erfolgreich sagen wir mal Schadenersatz oder etwas ähnliches einklagt weil eine App im App Store irgendwas gemacht hat was die Nutzerin nicht wollte.
Könnte kommen, aber wird mit einem separaten Markt natürlich dann komplett wegfallen.
Na, also äh vielleicht, um das noch mal kurz ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, ich meine die Idee,
ein äh auf das iPhone als Erfindung.
Einen App Store zu machen, warscheinlich oder war mit Sicherheit äh
sehr viel Mehrwert als die Idee überhaupt ein iPhone zu machen. Ne, also der App Store ist ähm ein ein äußerst eine
äußerst ertragreiche Idee und ähm ich würde mal,
sehr schwer vermuten, dass äh Apple sich dessen auch im Klaren war, als sie quasi gesagt haben, okay, wir haben hier dieses Gerät, ähm wir möchten, dass Entwicklern ähm zur Verfügung stellen. Was ist damals äh schief oder was.
PC-Markt, was uns nicht gefällt. Ja, Raubkopiererei ähm.
Und ähm potentiell Leute, die irgendwelche Software machen, die wir nicht gut finden, die also Ungemach
in äh unser Ökosystem bringen und unzufriedene Menschen. Also lass uns einen App Store machen, den wir kontrollieren, wo ein
wo Regeln gelten und vor allem an dem wir äh mit partizipieren, ja und,
das ist das eine, das war eine Milliardenidee und die hat Apple äh sehr, sehr viel Geld gebracht. Gleichzeitig haben wir, und das ist ja das, wovon ähm eigentlich dieser gesamte Digital Markets Act,
letztendlich redet äh und auch was Jan die ganze Zeit äh benennt. Das hier.
Plattformen geschaffen werden, die Marktanteile haben.
Und das Entstehen äh weiterer Plattformen äh eigentlich,
ausschließen. Ja ähm eine das also eine derartige Marktmacht existiert und dass sich quasi das Monopol.
Von Apple für
den Markt, den sie sich da selber geschaffen haben äh sich selbst manifestiert und zwar nicht nur dadurch, dass du mal ein iPhone kaufst
dann sagst, ah okay, hier haben wir diese App und jetzt kaufe ich mir ein Android, sondern dass du irgendwann ja auch zum Beispiel also je länger du ein iPhone nutzt, desto teurer wird.
Der Umzug auf.
In eine Android Ökosystem, ja? Und das wird bei das ist bei Microsoft äh Window Systemen äh dann ähnlich, weil diese App Storeidee
Die wird ja jetzt auch auf alles andere übernommen. Das ist ja also ist ja hat ja in
Einzug erhalten und wird dort ähm sieht man mit jedem Betriebssystem-Update, wie die,
sage ich mal die ähm Lanz äh die die wie heißt das, die Schwelle höher wird, dass du da überhaupt noch irgendeine freie Software drauf kriegst. Ähm
wir sehen den Windows App Store und letztendlich werden alle diese Hardwarehersteller.
Dem der Strategie folgen wie es die.
Softwarehersteller äh vormachen zu sagen, okay wir schaffen uns hier Kunden fürs Leben. Ja, der Tim, der der wird.
Der wird in seinem Leben kein Android-Telefon mehr
kaufen. Das kannst du von ausgehen, ne? Und genau das ist natürlich, also wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, wie viele Jahrzehnte so ein Mensch lebt und wie wie wie viel Einkommen man sich damit
sichern kann und wie viel Konkurrenz man sich damit vom Leib hält, ist es natürlich äh sinnvoll.
Eine äh Regulierung sich darüber Gedanken macht, wie man da irgendwie überhaupt noch eine ähm Konkurrenz aufrecht erhalten kann
argumentieren die natürlich. Tja äh Konkurrenz gibt's ja. Wir haben es gibt ja Android, die haben ja sogar noch viel mehr Marktanteil als wir, ne? Aber die Frage ist natürlich dann.
Wie man das erreichen kann oder ob wir sagen, okay, wir geben uns geschlagen. Deswegen will ich am Ende im Prinzip sagen, ja jetzt das Öffnen des iPhones für weitere ähm App Stores.
Hielte ich jetzt zunächst einmal nicht für.
Für schlimm, auch wenn ich auf der also ne da wird der Gesetzgeber äh jetzt keinen Schaden anrichten ähm auch wenn ich mit Sicherheit wahrscheinlich dieses Häkchen weglassen würde.
Vorausgesetzt, es wird eins.
Aber ich finde die in äh ich finde die äh die die Debatte grade also diese diese mehreren Seiten finde ich gerade echt sehr spannend, das mal.
Darzustellen. Ich bin da auf jeden Fall.
Also mir bei mir schlagen da auch zwei Herzen in der Brust. Wenn ich mir überlege, wie viele Jahrzehnte ich wahrscheinlich noch in den Apple-Konzernen ähm.
Reinbuttern werde und welche Zumutungen ich mir im Zweifelsfall noch alles von denen antun lassen werde, ja? Potentiell wär's für mich irgendwann mal reizvoll, diese ähm.
Diese Content-Scanning Ambitionen von diesem Gerät äh verbannen zu können, ne. Vielleicht dadurch, dass ich eine andere Cloud nutze, als die, die äh sie mir ähm mitliefern.
Also da gibt's auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu regulieren. Also ich.
Gut, man kann da jetzt sich ein bisschen im Kreis halten. Ich habe auch ein Problem an der Stelle mit diesem App Store
ja? Ähm und äh sehe da auch einen Regulierungsbedarf. Ich sehe den.
Nur an anderen Stellen. Ja, also es ist hat sehr viel mehr mit irgendwie Payment äh generell zu tun. Es ist aber auch genauso ein schwieriger Bereich. Und ich finde auch, dass.
Der der Aspekt Security hier auch äh mit zum Tragen kommen muss, weil definitiv ist das natürlich jetzt hier auch technisch alles so in einem Topf,
Ja und das muss man dann gut trennen, was,
eigentlich auf was eine eine Auswirkung, ist ja auch Argumentation, na ja äh macht das ja alles unsicher und das ist auch,
Kein schlechtes Argument, ob wir das sicherlich auch noch mal ein bisschen auseinandernehmen kann. Ja, genauso wie dieses Monopol, also wo fängt dann Monopol an? Ja, Monopol auf der eigenen Plattform, ja. Das hat jeder. Jeder hat auf seiner eigenen Plattform Monopol. Im Markt haben sie halt kein Monopol.
Vielleicht so eine Oligopol-Situation ähm wodurch ist die entstanden? Das das das die,
das so wollten, die da jetzt gerade sind,
weiß ich nicht. Sicherlich haben sie nichts dagegen, dass sie Microsoft nicht noch mit äh dazu gesprungen ist, mit einer dritten äh Plattform an der Stelle. Hat wahrscheinlich einfach der Markt aber einfach mit
mit der ganzen Plattform, mit der Netzwerkdynamik, die wir überall sehen im Internet, äh dafür gesorgt, dass es eben
sehr viel weniger sind und für in gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja auch von von Vorteil, dass man da eben nicht.
Dreißig verschiedene Plattformen hat und nix läuft richtig irgendwo, ne? Also das das hat ja alles so seinen seinen äh vorne und hinten. Also ich.
Bin nur mit diesen mit dieser generellen Betrachtung das jetzt ein anderer Distributionskanal für Apps da irgendwas verbessert.
Dem kann ich nicht folgen. So ähm ich sehe eine Regulationsbedarf, sehr viel mehr in diesem Bereich.
Nach welchen Regeln entscheidet ihr, ob's Apps gibt oder nicht? Die Zahl von Apps, die jetzt wirklich umstritten sind, die es nicht gibt, die man nicht bekommen hat, ist eigentlich.
Überschaubar. Also es gibt gab zwar immer mal wieder ein paar Aufreger
aber auf der einen Seite irgendwann auch gelegt haben und wo man eben auch wirklich vielleicht auch ansetzen kann und sagen kann, okay, es muss jetzt hier irgendwie einen Prozess geben, dass diese Art Apps irgendwie exist,
können. Die könnt ihr nicht einfach mal, weil's euch äh nicht ins Business-Modell passt, außen vorlassen, ja? Wie wird Streaming? Wie werden äh Streaming-Verträge äh also Verträge, die außerhalb eines App Stores geschlossen sind
dürfen die innerhalb eines App Stores laufen oder dürft ihr vorschreiben, dass das nicht zu sein hat. Das ist ja eigentlich eher das Problem, wo's auch wirklich um um Geld und um,
um Macht geht und man sieht ja auch heute schon, dass äh in dem Moment, wo die Macht groß ist, äh Apple,
Genauso Google wahrscheinlich. Ich habe jetzt mehr den Einblick bei Apple auch Konzessionen macht, ne. So dieses äh Amazon-Bücher, die du woanders gekauft hast äh äh
Dürfen die dann da abgespielt werden et cetera? Hat sich Apple auch oft irgendwie gegen äh gewehrt, hat aber dann doch immer wieder intern so eine Lex Amazon gemacht, wo dann für Amazon für Netflix Ausnahmen gehalten, die aber nicht für alle gehalten und das ist meiner Meinung nach eher der Bereich,
regulatorisch rangehen sollte. Da klare Regeln zu schaffen, dann hat man auch nicht ein Problem damit, dass es einen App Store gibt, weil dieser App Store einfach Regeln zu folgen hat, anstatt dass man zehn verschiedene äh Stores hat, die alle irgendwie genau jeder einen anderen Scheiß machen und ist mir das letzten Endes auch nicht weiterhilft.
Dabei noch die Security äh unter die Räder kommen. Das ist so ein bisschen mein Punkt.
Okay, wir sehen, äh in welchem komplizierten Bereich die EU da jetzt äh regulieren muss. Äh haben wir noch weitere.
Dinge, die sich ändern sollen, ändern werden bei den Gelb-Keita den.
Gate Keeperdiensten, denen der DSDMA zu Leibe rücken soll. Meine Güte.
Äh ja äh die Liste ist lang. Ähm ich glaube es sind insgesamt über 20 verschiedene äh äh Verpflichtungen und und und Gebote.
Die da die da aufgenommen sind eine der Sachen die vielleicht noch nennenswert sind ist ein Verbot für Geldkeeper ohne,
vorheriges Einverständnis der an unseren Nutzer äh Daten über mehrere Dienste hinweg. Persönliche Daten über mehrere Dienste hinweg zu kombinieren miteinander,
Ähm und äh der Gedanke dahinter ist, dass eben äh Marktmacht auch daraus entsteht, äh dass ein Unternehmen, was schon ein
Zugriff hat auf riesige Daten halten, äh eben diese dann auch nutzen kann, äh um in einem anderen Markt Fuß zu fassen. Ähm leichter als das vielleicht
Wettbewerber könnten. Und äh also eine Beispiel wäre die Nutzung von äh äh von Daten aus WhatsApp
um äh Werbung in Facebook anzureichern oder andere Facebook-Dienste an
zu bieten oder Google benutzt, Daten aus Gmail, um damit seine Suche zu verbessern, die persönliche Suche Suchergebnisse zu verbessern, solche Sachen. Ähm.
Und äh und da gibt's also eine ein eine Klausel, die das äh einschränken würde für Geldkeeper. Ähm
Und äh die ansonsten hat das Europäische Parlament noch.
On top für die App-Stories hinzugefügt, dass sie gesagt haben, wir wollen auch, dass Gate-Keeper
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer auf der Plattform Optionen anbieten müssen. Ähm wir haben das schon als eine der Ergebnisse von einen der äh Wettbewerbsfälle, die die Kommission geführt hat gegen Google, dass Google jetzt so einen
Auswahlscreen auf neuen Android-Telefonen anzeigen muss, mit welche Browsers alles zur Verfügung
um die Marktmacht von Chrome zu brechen. Das war damals die Idee, dass so eine von den klassischen Entscheidungen in der Kommission, die viel zu spät kamen, nachdem Chrome schon längst
die Herrschaft übernommen hatte. Ähm aber dabei ist eben der Vorschlag, okay, kannte der DM der DMA nicht
allen Geldkeepern vorschreiben eben äh dort Alternativen mit vorzuschlagen, wo der Geldkeeper eine eigene App
in seiner Plattform hat. Also Beispiel wäre dann nicht nur Google muss andere Browser vorschlagen, sondern Google muss auch andere Suchmaschinen vorschlagen. Google muss andere Maps-Anbieter vorschlagen. Ähm und und so weiter und so fort. Also immer da, wo dann der
auch eigene Produkte mit am Start hat und äh ob das jetzt kommt, wie gesagt, ist jetzt noch unklar, weil das man jetzt in in der Position des Parlamentes.
Drin ist. Wie das genau ausgestaltet werden
soll und kann, ist auch noch nicht ganz ausgegoren, ähm ohne, dass man jetzt irgendwie beim ersten Anschalten des Geräts mit Fragen überschüttet wird.
Das das muss sich muss man dann sicherlich in den Detailverhandlungen klären, aber das sind so einige der der Dinge, die jetzt auf der Liste noch drin stehen im im DMA, die direkt sich auch
für eine zu rettenden Nutzer dann in der Praxis bemerkbar machen würden.
Okay. Sonst noch was?
Ich glaube, das sind die großen Punkte, die da die da zur Debatte stehen
und ein Teil davon wird es sicherlich ins Finale gesetzt schaffen. Äh die Verpflichtung für alternative App Stores wird mit großer Sicherheit im finalen Gesetz drin stehen. Das wäre also sehr spannend dann in drei Jahren nochmal äh eine Podcast-Folge zusammen zu machen und zu schauen äh wie das Ergebnis letztendlich äh.
Ausgegangen ist.
Ja, da sind wir auf jeden Fall gespannt. Ich glaube ähm schon seit längerem ist klar, dass das jetzt äh
also von der Bedeutung her eines der der großen äh Gesetze mal wieder ist. Also der Vergleich zur DSGVO bietet sich an.
Vor allem auch weil was da jetzt einmal drin geregelt wird, das ist dann eben geregelt und was da nicht drin geregelt wird und es da nicht reinschafft, das wird dann wahrscheinlich oder mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auch.
Dauerhaft ungeregelt bleiben, es sei denn,
es gibt vielleicht noch irgendwelche auf Seiten der USA noch irgendwelche Markteingriffe die in diesem Land ja generell eher äh nicht zu erwarten sind ne.
Insofern wird er sicherlich entweder durch Entscheidungen und eben auch durch nicht Entscheidungen sicherlich eine ganze Menge für das also im Internet.
Äh geklärt, zementiert oder aufgebrochen, ne.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube auch, dass wenn's um die Beschränkung der Macht von diesen großgrößten der Tech-Konzerne geht, ähm können wir vermutlich jetzt nicht auf große Aktionen aus den USA hoffen. Das müssen wir, glaube ich, schon selber machen.
Ja Jan, ähm vielen Dank an der Stelle für die ganzen äh Ausführungen.
Ich hoffe äh ihr kriegt dann noch das ein oder andere Gerade lobbyiert irgendwie. Erfahrung hast du damit ja ähm.
Geht so der Ädry an sich, habt ihr genug Geld?
Äh so weit ich da einen Überblick habe, können wir uns aktuell äh ich meine, klar, ähm mehr Ressourcen ist immer besser im Vergleich zu dem, was Google und Facebook so haben. Es ist ist es natürlich vernachlässigbar, ähm aber ich glaube, es ist schon ist schon okay, so wie wir jetzt arbeiten.
Ah, jetzt hast du die Chance verpasst, Spenden einzuwerben, Pech gehabt. Müssen die.
Das gibt Ärger.
Die Leute an uns spenden.
Kollegin einladen.
Gebt dem gebt dem Tim Geld, dann kauft er sich Apps.
Ist so teuer im Appstore, weißt du?
Nein, äh wir verlinken trotzdem, auch wenn wenn äh wenn du äh sagst, das ist momentan mit dem Funding gut steht, äh glaube ich, dass äh Budget ähm hm.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Minuten die Lobbyisten, der Tech-Giganten in Brüssel für das Geld arbeiten, mit dem.
Edry.
Ganzes Jahr arbeitet. Allein was jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass die so viel mehr verdienen, sondern wahrscheinlich erstens mehr verdienen, aber zweitens auch mehr Menschen sind ähm Edris sind, wie viele äh Vollzeitstellen.
Wir haben 13 Vollzeitstellen derzeit. Die Hälfte davon macht Politik ähm und man muss sich vorstellen, so Unternehmen wie Google und Facebook haben ungefähr 13 Leute, die nur am DSA arbeiten und zwar in jeder Hauptstadt in Europa.
Ja.
Komm ihr seid doch schlank und beweglich und ist auch ein Vorteil.
Vor allem die besseren Argumente auf.
Für die Rechte aller Menschen und nicht nur für die Rechte eines großen Konzern.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Viel Freude und fühlt sich gut an.
Super.
Wir danken dir, dass du die.
Geduld mit uns hattest, das alles äh so schön zu erklären. Ähm wir wünschen.
Euch äh Erfolg.
Und ähm würden uns freuen, äh wenn wir dich zu gegebener Zeit auch wieder einladen können, wenn sich da.
Äh nennenswertes bewegt. Es gibt ja dann immer.
Noch viele aufregende äh Situationen im auf den letzten Drückern bei der Verabschiedung solcher Gesetze,
solcher Acts und wer dann da nochmal aus der Reihe fällt und wer sich überraschend anders überlegt und wer doch von Google gekauft ist
äh wo Axel Voss wieder irgendwas mitm Arsch einreist. Das wird ja äh das kommt ja jetzt noch alles und da freuen wir uns auch drauf.
Gut, dann äh machen wir an dieser Stelle Schluss. Äh wir sagen äh tschüss und äh bis bald. Vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören und ja irgendwann nächste Woche melden wir uns dann äh wieder mit.
Mit richtig depressiven Themen, wie das hier äh üblich ist, ne. Ciao.
Tschau, tschau.